Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du redest doch auch manchmal dummes Zeug. Willst du nicht Regierungsberater werden?
Ich muss gerade nur überlegen, wovon ich so richtig überhaupt keine Ahnung habe.
So richtig keine Ahnung haben wir vom Podcast und wir wissen auch nicht, wie wir mit Communitys umgehen und schon gar nicht äh wie wir mit dem Internet umgehen und deswegen empfehlen wir uns als,
Experten für den ja fast wöchentlichen Rückblick auf das Netzpolitische Geschehen, ne?
Experten
kennst du dieses geile Expertenvideo im Internet, wo dann so diese Marketing-Runde zusammensitzt und irgendwie ein Experte mit seinem Sales äh Guy und,
Kunde möchte dann gerne rote Linien, die aber irgendwie transparent aber dann trotzdem auch grün sind und irgendwie Dreiecke, die alle parallel zueinander verlaufen und so. Und der Experte.
Mit den Augen und sagt irgendwie äh bitte was äh habt ihr sie noch alle? Und der Sale ist geil, hm, sag mal, ruhig so, nee, nee, nee, das das kriegen wir schon alles hin. Sieht so ein bisschen aus wie so eine D E Mail äh Besprechungsrunde.
Ich erinnere mich, ich erinnere mich, ich.
Den Link schmeißen wir auch gleich noch in die Show Nots. Das das ist so ein bisschen so den Eindruck, den ich manchmal habe, wenn so die Personalkarusselle so vor sich hin rotieren und irgendwie immer wieder so richtige super spezial äh Experten produzieren. Und dann auch noch immer dieselben.
Ja aber äh.
Da kommen wir noch zu.
Es ist, ich es hat ja ich glaube, ich unterstelle da ja bei einigen Stellen bösartigkeit, aber da kommen wir ja dann gleich, da kommen wir ja gleich essen.
Ja, das kann gut sein, das kann gut sein. Also zumindest uns gegenüber.
Ja, aber weiße Tim, ne? Weiß ja, äh nur weil wir unseren Körner selbst kompilieren, sind wir keine Genies, ne.
Das stimmt.
Ne? Und wir wir äh haben uns uns ja gar nicht anmaßen dass wir in irgendwelchen Bereichen hier Einfluss auf die Politik nehmen könnten, weil wir sind ja nur Arschlöcher.
Nerds. Ja, Nerds auch. Ja. So läuft.
Arschlöcher.
Ja, aber die anderen sind ja auch nicht.
Hat der, glaube ich, wirklich schon mal gesagt. Nee, der hat, der hat sowas gesagt wie äh ähm man darf die Netzpolitik nicht den Nerds äh überlassen.
Nee, nee. Wo kommen wir denn da auch hin?
Ja, ja, ja, Herr. Aber jetzt sind wir schon wieder doch wieder schon wieder beim übernächsten Thema oder willst du da gerade irgendwas vorziehen? Nee.
Nee, Afrika, ich äh fand, ich fand das eigentlich nur ganz, ganz lustig, welche Debatte sich entsponnen hat, um das, um das zehnjährige Bestehen von Fefes Block.
Ach so, ja.
Das das würde ich ja an dieser Stelle doch nochmal ganz gerne würdigen. Also das ist, ich fand das eigentlich eine sehr interessante Debatte, weil glaube ich, ohne Frage äh viel, viel in den
in den zehn Jahren seines Bloggens äh durch eine Menge Feinde gemacht hat und äh einige von denen haben sich ja dann auch zu seinem zu den Festlichkeiten seines zehnjährigen Bloggens äh auch zu zu Wort gemeldet
durchaus mit äh sehr ähm wichtigen Kritikpunkten. Ähm,
an der Veröffentlichung, ne? Also gab äh in den vielen Jahren einiges, äh wo er, glaube ich, auf auf einige Leute, einigen Leuten das Leben sehr schwer gemacht hat, was äh nicht mehr im Bereich des.
Äh angenehm war. Ähm übrigens auch ich, ich habe auch schon in äh,
für Aktion oder sagen wir mal für Aktionen von mir nicht unbedingt namentlich ein auf den Sack bekommen und weiß auch wie sich das anfühlt,
aber was ich eigentlich ganz, ganz wichtig finde in dem Zusammenhang wurde auch immer wieder diese Forderungen laut, ähm dass man sich bestimmter,
Veröffentlichung eben entziehen müsse, ja? Also dass man bestimmte Blogs dürfe man nicht lesen, ne? Also man,
Don Alfron, so dürfe man nicht lesen, weil das ein konservativer ähm äh ist und Fefe darf man nicht lesen und äh was um Bild-Zeitungen darf man auch nicht lesen. Ähm ich halte das für ähm
für ganz, ganz besonders gefährlich so zu argumentieren. Ich lese insbesondere die Sachen, die nicht das sagen, was ich denke.
Das muss ich tun, weil ich mich im politischen Bereich vor allem mit den Argumentationen der anderen auseinandersetzen muss. Ja, ich meine, Lokbuchnetzpolitik ist schön und gut, wenn wir hier ähm
den dem Chor predigen und äh uns darüber freuen, dass der Chor immer größer wird, ja? Und das ist ja auch äh schön.
Aber ich ähm hoffe doch, dass ich bei aller äh subjektiver Prägung hier insbesondere auch die Position, die Gegenposition ausreichend immer äh versuche zu erklären und zu würdigen,
und ähm das gelingt mir ja nicht, wenn ich mich da auf das äh auf den Punkt herunter begebe zu sagen das sind jetzt irgendwie Konservative, das sind Arschlöcher, von denen kommt nur schlechtes. Letzte Woche noch darüber gesprochen, dass wir jetzt auch einen Niko Lummer bei der bei der Bild-Zeitung haben und ähm es ist für für
die geistige ähm Diskursfähigkeit ganz besonders wichtig, sich mit dem auseinanderzusetzen, was,
was die Gegenseite sagt. Und wenn man in als die Gegenseite sieht, dann ist es, glaube ich, auch wichtig, das zu lesen, um,
nicht in so einer ähm,
in so einer, in so einer Filter-Bubble da zu landen, in der man dann nur noch äh überall den Feind sieht und ähm sich gegenseitig das.
Ja und das ist auch.
Ist auch ich meine, ja, stimmt so, ja, also erstmal man man wird man muss alles lesen dürfen, finde ich auf jeden Fall, so also.
Man muss das vor allem auch lesen.
Man, ja, also das weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob man alles lesen muss, weiß ich nicht. Man muss nicht alles lesen.
Nein, das stimmt. Ich äh zu lesen ist kein Muss. Äh zu lesen ist ähm da kann man sich drüber, äh kann man sich viel drüber amüsieren. Das ist halt so einfache äh einfache
Darstellungen für die Mittagspause und natürlich,
wir glaube in einer seiner Würdigung braucht man eben nicht nur eine Prise Salz, sondern direkt so ein ganzen Salzstreuer,
dazu, wenn man das Blog liest, ja und da passieren regelmäßig auch üble Ausrutscher, ja? Also ich,
Grade in meinem Freundeskreis auch Menschen, die da regelmäßig ähm betroffen sind, ne, also so,
stell dir mal vor, du würdest an an System die äh entwickeln, ne, dann dann liest du irgendwann
Block nicht mehr, weil ähm ja, weil da halt einfach Unwahrheiten äh und und bösartige Anschuldigungen über über deine über dein ehrenamtliches Engagement da ähm getätigt werden,
Stell dir vor, du wärst für Hartleat verantwortlich und du wärst derjenige, dessen Name da genannt wurde.
Das sind schon äh Grenzen, die da überschritten werden und ähm natürlich ist das äh schwierig, wenn Menschen diese,
Artikel dann eben ohne Salzstreuer lesen,
Und da auf äh auf so einen Quatsch dann oder auf solche Angriffe dann äh auch anspringen und einspringen. Das ist äh das ist ziemlich übel. Und das kann man eigentlich auch nur sagen, dass äh diese Menschen,
dass diesen Menschen Basale, das Verständnis des Zusammenlebens fehlt,
und wie auch angemerkt wurde, kann man da sicherlich auch den Kritikpunkt üben, dass Hefe da ab und zu sich seiner Verantwortung als als äh sehr weit rezipiertes Blog äh nicht unbedingt vollständig gerecht wird.
Ja, genau, das ist das ist Hauptsache, man braucht ein interessanter Aspekt. Ich meine, ähm es gibt halt Leute, die sind ähm
wie soll ich sagen, sind da, sind so, haben verstanden, dass sie Reichweite haben und nutzen das auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise. Ich habe halt auch festgestellt, ich meine, bei mir ist es ja auch so
dass ich jetzt durch die mediale Arbeit in den äh letzten Jahren eine gewisse Reichweite habe. Also auf der einen Seite äh zwei Sachen muss man machen. Man darf sie nicht überschätzen,
Also man darf seine eigene Deutungshoheit auf jeden Fall nicht man darf sich selbst nicht zu wichtig nehmen. Man darf nicht glauben, weil man jetzt
irgendwas so und so darstellt, wäre das eine Meinung, die alle übernehmen würden. Das das wäre dann einfach so, es wäre irgendwie besonders wichtig oder man müsste Gegenargumente nicht gewichten. Das ist definitiv eine Gefahr, die äh,
die man schnell reinläuft. Auf der anderen Seite äh darf man's aber auch nicht unterschätzen. Man darf nicht,
meinen, weil man sich selber vielleicht nicht so wichtig nimmt oder weil man das.
Weißt du, weil's ja nur das mein Gedanke ist, findet alles irgendwie in meinem Kopf statt. Dann blöke ich das so ins Internet und ist ja die Schuld der anderen, wenn dir das irgendwie zu wichtig nehmen.
Tatsache ist, dass einfach viele Leute werden, ähm so ein bisschen,
aus einem Film heraus oder aus dem Hype heraus oder auch einfach nur durch eine Fehlwahrnehmung irgendwie als als Leithandel und und wichtige Personen gewertet, die sie vielleicht manchmal auch sind, ja?
Aber das übersetzt sich nicht automatisch dadrin, dass dann irgendwie jedes, jedes Wort Gesetz ist. Und es gibt Leute, die haben eine sehr, wie soll ich sagen.
Eine sehr einfache Art und Weise mit gesammelten Informationen umzugehen. Da ist man dann irgendwie so eingenordet, ja und äh Tim hat jetzt gesagt, das und das und deswegen, weißt du, ist das so
so. Was Quatsch ist, weil ähm ich mir
ich zumindest versuche mir immer wieder anzugewöhnen, auch auch meine eigenen Aussagen zu hinterfragen und vor allem auch muss man eben gut darüber, wenn es gelingt einem noch nicht immer, ja, gut darüber nachdenken, was sagt man jetzt und wie sagt man das?
Dass irgendwie klar ist, dass im Prinzip bei allem, was ich sage, du sagst, wir sagen, äh jeder auch immer so ein bisschen mitgeschwungen bekommt, so.
Nimmt es an, macht dir deinen Kopf dadrüber, aber macht es vor allem und bilde deine eigene Meinung und ist auch okay, wenn du zu einer anderen,
Schlussfolgerung kommst und besser noch das würde ich dann auch gerne wissen
Weil man verrennt sich da sehr schnell und und und an seiner eigenen Glaubenswelt festzuhängen und der Rest ist ja alles egal und man ist ja auch egal, was ich für eine Wirkung habe, wenn ich falsch wahrgenommen werde, ist das das Problem der Anderen. Das halte ich für den falschen Ansatz.
Feefe ist da schwierig, ja. Ich meine, wer ihn länger kennt und ich kenne den länger als diese zehn Jahre, ja, das ist jetzt, sagen wir mal nichts, was erst mit seiner Blocktätigkeit
so aufgekommen ist. Er hat dann etwas,
einfache Art und Weise des des äh Vorgehens und ähm na ja, viele müssen interpretieren das und ich finde es insofern ein bisschen beunruhigend und das ist auch das, was sagen wir mal, der von dir genannten Kritik auch so ein bisschen mit Schwang.
Wenn dann halt so ein bisschen so ein Mob von Leichtgläubigen oder Leuten, die weißt du, eben dann eben nicht bereit sind, da jetzt viel Gedanken zu verschwenden, da so ein bisschen da ihre Botschaften erhalten, dann einfach losschießen. Man hat ja auch schon mal über dieses super extreme Gamergate und so weiter,
ähm gesprochen. Ich will das jetzt hier nicht auf eine Ebene setzen, aber das da ist definitiv auch so eine ähnliche Dynamik mit drin, dass Leute dann einfach,
ne? Das nicht reflektieren, sondern ah, der Rest marschiert auch mit in die Richtung. Da mache ich das jetzt auch mal auch bei anderen Nimos und so weiter. Also oft findet man das, wo dann einfach,
man das Gefühl hat, da werden jetzt einfach nicht mehr Argumente gewichtet, sondern da wird einfach nur noch Aktionismus verbreitet.
Genau und das hat man aber doch bei einigen, genau bei diesen einigen äh Wortbeiträgen auch gesehen. Also wie gesagt, ich halte es grundsätzlich für falsch zu sagen,
den nicht lesen. Ich finde das sehr wichtig zu sagen
das, was in diesem Artikel bezahlbar behauptet wurde oder das, was diese Person da getan hat, ist aus folgenden Gründen falsch, ja? Ähm
Zum Beispiel ärgere ich mich sehr, dass ich mich äh gegen einige Artikel, in denen unwahre Behauptungen über meine Person verbreitet werden, äh nicht gewehrt habe, einfach um ihn keine Aufmerksamkeit äh zuzuschieben. Ähm.
Oder ich ärgere mich darüber, dass diese Behauptungen aufgestellt wurden. Ich bin eigentlich ganz froh darüber, dass ich dass ich da nicht äh drauf geantwortet habe, weil das eben aus dieser Hassinternecke kommt. Ja, es gibt halt eine Hassecke im Internet und in der gibt's Menschen,
und äh in einigen ähm in in vielen dieser Hass-Internetecken ähm spielt eben auch eine Rolle.
Und äh das spielt er mal als als Ziel und mal als äh oder viel häufiger ähm,
oder viel häufiger als Ziel dieser Hassattacken, aber natürlich auch in vielen Fällen und in vielen signifikanten und schlimmen Fällen dann eben auch als als Auslöser dieser Hassattacken auf andere.
Ne? Das ist generell einfach scheiße. Was äh wie wie Menschen da miteinander umgehen, wie Menschen da miteinander kommunizieren und ähm dieser Aspekt.
Ist auch nicht schön zu reden,
Ich denke aber, dass das Wichtigste dagegen ist, äh zu sagen, jedes Mal, wenn dir jemand dazu rät,
etwas anderes gar nicht erst zu lesen, ja, dann bist du auf jeden Fall schon mal auf einem Weg, der dich genau in so eine Hassecke führt. Ja
Ich finde das ist super wichtig, sich kritisch damit auseinanderzusetzen und man hat vor allem bei FIFA ein Problem, dass äh relativ wenige sich natürlich trauen äh sich mit ihm anzulegen oder auch mal eine falsche Behauptung von ihm
oder eine eine Arschloch-Aktion irgendwie ähm da entsprechend ähm.
Anzugreifen oder klarzustellen oder auch mal bloß zu stellen oder oder richtig zu rücken oder was auch immer,
Das ist, das ist durchaus ein Problem, aber wenn wenn dann ich ähm wenn ich dann von von bestimmten Personengruppen einfach grundsätzlich,
als Meinung dargestellt und wahrgenommen und diffamiert werde
finde ich das auch nicht in Ordnung, ne? Das sind äh Leute, von denen halt ich mich fern grundsätzlich von Menschen, die irgendwie an einem Austausch nicht interessiert sind und irgendwie davon aufrufen, bestimmte Dinge nicht zu lesen. Nein, lest das nicht, ne? Hier guckt das nicht an. Das äh das ist äh das ist also richtig, richtig äh schwach.
Zum Beispiel äh liegt im am Flughafen immer dieser dieser Fokus, ne, da kriege ich jedes Mal,
und und haste nicht gesehen, da kriege ich wirklich ein mieses Faschobblatt,
und dann nehme ich das und dann gucke ich da rein und dann lese ich, was da drin steht, ähm um mich darüber zu zu ärgern und um auch zu gucken, wo kann ich denn.
Äh andere Informationen finden, ja, also ich meine, die setzen sich auch mit Themen auseinander, von denen ich keine Ahnung habe, ja. Und es gehört eben zu einem,
es gehört eben dazu, sich äh die Meinungen anderer anzutun, auch wenn es weh tut. Und genau da ist Fefe,
vielen Jahren für mich dann auch in in einer Weise wertvoll geworden, weil ähm viele Male,
den Finger ins einen sehr salzigen Finger äh in sehr kleine Wunden gelegt hat, die einem dann ähm helfen.
Was weiß ich, die nächste Aktion ähm besser hinzukriegen oder so,
ja? Das ähm ich mir geht's gar nicht darum, jetzt irgendwie, also Fefe ist ein, ein Phänomen, das äh viele Facetten hat, das sehr, dass man sehr kritisch betrachten kann. Ich persönlich ähm
habe keinen Schaden davongetragen, das zu lesen,
ja? Aber ich maße mir auch an, dass ich das äh mit mit einem mit dem großen Salzstreuer lese,
und äh wer nie etwas anderes liest, was es zu hinterfragen gilt, der lernt auch nicht mit diesem Salzstreuer umzugehen. Und ähm das ist dann eben auch schade.
Ja, ich denke auch, dass äh meine die äh die Leute, die das jetzt kritisieren und die da sozusagen kritische Punkte sehen und so, das finde ich auch völlig in Ordnung, dass sie das äußern, ob die sich jetzt im Rahmen dieser zehn Jahre äh Jubelfestation auf dem Blog
dazu entschieden haben, dass äh in dem Blog selber zu machen, in dem Blog nochmal anonym oder dann auf dem eigenen Blog, ist mir eigentlich ziemlich äh egal. Ein wenig durcheinander war das schon
Andererseits ist so dieses Aufregen sich darüber groß aufregen, macht man natürlich so ein bisschen auch diesen, diesen Fehler, dass man damit natürlich
auch Relevanz unterstellt. Und äh manchmal ist es einfach besser, irgendwas einfach zu ignorieren,
ja? Und zu sagen,
okay, tangiert mich nicht. Ich äußere mich da nicht zu und dann ist eigentlich auch gut. Das ist nämlich auch eine Aussage. Anstatt sich da manchmal in so,
so schweres geschützt zu verrennen, was dann meistens auch ein wenig über das Ziel hinausgeht.
Das wäre sowieso mal schön. Also ich bin jetzt, also der ohne jetzt explizit mal ohne bestimmte Personen da jetzt anzusprechen, ja? Man fragt sich ja schon.
Wenn man so Internet guckt, ne, guck's Internet, machst du mal so ein Twitter auf oder so.
Also über was für Themen Menschen sich da auseinander aufregen und über was für Themen die sich ereifern können, ne? Das ist schon echt manchmal sehr, sehr ähm,
sehr, sehr überraschend. Da fehlt mir so ein bisschen ähm.
Da fehlt mir so ein bisschen die Zeit zu. Ich bin vielleicht ein bisschen zu ähm zu ausgelastet und ich glaube, wenn man irgendwie feststellt, dass man zu oft äh am Internet sitzt und sich aufregt,
Und wenn man vielleicht schon gar nicht mehr weiß, woran man sich letzte Woche aufgeregt hat, dann muss man mal gucken, ob man nicht vielleicht so ähm.
Man guckt, wie man irgendwie so die Zeit seines Lebens verbringen möchte, ne, ob man sich vielleicht was eine Tätigkeit sucht, was Schaffendes, ne? Vielleicht mal guckt, ob man sich beruflich umorientiert oder überhaupt mal beruflich orientiert. Und ähm
dass man mal schaut, so worauf man selber in seinem Leben.
Ja gut, also nicht äh ja.
Hinarbeiten möchte. MS Pro hat mal sehr schön getwittert, das fand ich super, irgendwie das aber Jahre her hat er gesagt, wie bitte Lücke im Lebenslauf zwischen zweitausend so und so und zweitausend so und so war ich ein sehr erfolgreicher Twitterer. Das fand ich.
Drüber schmunzeln, das fand ich einen großartigen Tweet.
Oder oder ich ich hatte äh wenn ich einen kleinen Tweet, einen kleinen Tweet von mir, Tim, ich weiß, ich bin ich bin schlimm, aber einen kleinen Tweet von mir, ich habe irgendwie äh letztens äh getwittert, äh.
Äh die zweitausendzehner waren gute Jahre. Wir haben mehrere wichtige Hashtags initiiert. Das fand ich witzig.
Ja, genau.
Na ja, okay.
Geneigte Hörer wird schon äh bemerkt haben, dass so unsere Unterbrechungsdynamik etwas schwierig ist, das ist natürlich geschuldet der Tatsache, dass wir mal wieder mehrere tausend Kilometer auseinander äh sind und entsprechenden Latenzen und äh Software, minderer Qualität zu kämpfen haben, man
möge es uns nachsehen.
Sorry.
So, das.
Das meinte ich übrigens mit dem mit dem mit dem erfüllten Leben. Aber egal. Machen wir weiter. Ich äh versteigere mich jetzt nur in Spitzen äh an äh Anmerkungen.
Genau, wir lassen das jetzt. Kommen wir zur Netzpolitik.
Ach ja äh stimmt, stimmt. Ähm kommen wir kommen wir wieder zu den zu den zu den Traurigen, zu den traurigen Geschichten.
Genau.
Ähm Andre war mal wieder im äh BND Untersuchungsausschuss und da war diesmal ein sehr äh interessanter Zeuge geladen, nämlich der Klaus Landefeld. Der Klaus Landefeld ist ähm Vorstand des Eco,
und äh Betreiber des Internetknoten-Dezixts in Frankfurt am Main. Und er hat da mal relativ ausführlich erzählt,
Was ist denn mit der Meldung von Spiegel Online aus dem Oktober zweitausenddreizehn auf sich hat?
Dass der BND am Dezix fünfundzwanzig Internetservice Provider,
anzapfen dürfe, darunter eins und eins freenet stark Strato.
QSC, Lambdanet und Plus-Server. Also so lange gehen jetzt diese Gerüchte schon zurück. Ja, Dezix, wie wir wissen, der große äh,
kann man Internet Exchange in in Europa eigentlich? Und einer der größten der Welt, wenn ich mich nicht täusche?
Bin ich der größte mittlerweile sogar.
Und also wobei ich nicht weiß, meinste ist echt das Ding in Frankfurt der Größte oder die der Estate den Dezix unterhält. Die haben ja auch in in New York irgendwie äh Dinger stehen.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob die anderen die Pendantsen da noch überhaupt nennenswert mit reinspielen. Also lange Zeit hatte ich die Kenntnis, dass Amsick ist eigentlich immer der größte Exchange war und ich glaube, Dezix hat das abgelöst. Aber ist ja auch egal. Die Schienen da wirklich viel Zeug durch und,
viele sind beteiligt und das ist wichtig und groß und ob das nun Platz eins, zwei, drei oder vier oder ob Singapur uns da nicht mittlerweile auch schon abgehängt hat, Hockers.
Da ist auf jeden Fall die haben die haben richtig fett Internet.
So viel wollen wir zu Hause auch haben. Ja, genau.
Ich habe ein neues Kabel gelesen, dem geht's besser.
Ja, hast du Goldkabel genommen?
Ja, klar, vergoldet.
Und du weißt ja, in den Kurven nicht so scharf legen, weil sonst die Atome rausfliegen, ne? Die Elektronen.
Ich hab's, ich hab's extra im Hifi Shop äh geholt und gesagt, das muss gut für Audio sein.
Ja, sehr schön, sehr schön.
Teuer.
Also äh Herr Landefeld erzählt, im August zweitausendacht inzwischen also vor sieben, ja, sechseinhalb Jahren,
Gab es dann in den Dezix-Geschäftsräumen ein erstes Planungsgespräch? Ähm
Zum Anzapfen von Kommunikationsleitungen. Das ist äh der äh belesene Historiker weiß es, ungefähr zu der Zeit, als diese Alconalsache zu Ende ging.
Und ähm die der BND wohl offensichtlich nach einem neuen Partner suchte.
Und in diesem Gespräch sagte, ja, wir hätten dann ganz gerne mal einen Generalzugriff auf alle Leitungen des Knotens
und dann dachte der BND dachte so ja ähm der Dezix dachte so ja okay wir können vielleicht irgendwie so,
euch bei Bedarf dann mal auf die eine oder andere draufschalten, wenn ihr uns das sagt. Und der BND sagte, nee, nee, wir wollen bitteschön einmal alles und äh ihr sollt auch nicht wissen, wo wir gerade reinschauen und so.
Und dann hat der Dezix das mal so seinen Rechtsanwälten gegeben, hat gesagt, da hat dann vermelden lassen, ja, wir haben das mal rechtlich geprüft, das kommt uns dann
ein bisschen unzulässig vor, was ihr hier macht. Und insbesondere stritten sie sich auch damals schon um die ähm zwanzig Prozent Regel. Ja, wir erinnern uns, das ist laut G zehn Gesetz äh,
erlaubt ist, zwanzig Prozent oder ich, nee, das ist gar nicht das G zehn Gesetz, sondern das gängige,
äh gängige Rechtsprechung, ne? Das ist nicht, das steht nicht wirklich im.
Mist. Ja, ich glaube, das ist sozusagen die Auslegung des Gezähn. Äh an der Stelle.
Zwanzig Prozent Regel. Genau, das ist ähm.
Wenn wir mal ein Juri.
Meldung von Netzpolitik ORG.
Okay, also nee, die die steht nicht im Gesetz drin, aber es gab es gab Debatten um die zwanzig Prozent Regel, ähm denn der Dezix hat gesagt, naja, der BND darf zwanzig Prozent,
tatsächlich anfallenden Verkehre pro Leitungen bekommen. Und der BND hat gesagt, nee, nee, wir wollen einfach mal grundsätzlich alles.
Und ähm zwanzig Prozent wenn die Leitung eben nur zu zwanzig Prozent ausgelastet sind, dann heißt das eben alles. Und,
danach gab's auch noch, da gibt's
irgendwie nur Andeutung drüber eben noch andere Vorstellungen von was ein Filtersystem ist um äh deutsche Grundrechtsträger äh heraus zu
filtern. Auf jeden Fall der der DCX hat dann gesagt, nee, das wollen wir nicht umsetzen, was ihr hier äh machen wollt. Und.
Dann hat der Dezix, weil er sich nicht anders zu helfen wusste, äh sich an die Mitglieder der ähm G zehn Kommission gewandt und hat gesagt äh ja hier, ihr seid doch hier G zehn Kommission. Bei uns steht hier gerade jemand vor der Tür, was machen wir denn hier, ne?
Das finden wir nicht in Ordnung, was hier passiert. Ähm und dann ähm dann.
Wurde wurde der Herr Landefeld und wahrscheinlich noch sein rechtlicher Beistand ins Kanzleramt bestellt, wo ihm gesagt wurde.
Seid ihr verrückt? Ihr dürft doch gar nicht mit der G zehn Kommission reden, denn die Maßnahme war noch gar nicht angeordnet.
Also ne ihr was wendet ihr euch an die G zehn Kommission, okay das hätte ich denen auch noch sagen können, dass die sich nicht an die G zehn Kommission wenden dürfen ähm aber wahrscheinlich haben sie es auch in genau dem Wissen getan.
Dürfen sie's nicht oder was? Also sie sind warum? Also warum dürfen sie sich da nicht dran wenden, weil die ist ja geheim oder was also ich meine, was,
Wenn, was was heißt denn, wenn also offiziell irgendeinen Antrag stellen oder überhaupt mit den Leuten reden?
In die die Kommission, in der G zehn Kommission wird ja quasi die Regierung geprüft.
So und da werden dann die in die zehn Kommission gehen, dann die Geheimdienste zum Beispiel rein und sagen, ja hallo und jetzt haben wir für die Regierung das und das und das und das und das gemacht. Und da muss die G zehn Kommission sagen, ja okay, okay, das scheint ja alles hier mit rechten Dingen zuzugehen
Ähm aber die G zehn Kommission kontrolliert, wenn ich das Recht erinnere, nicht die Geheimdienste, sondern eigentlich die Regierung. Und da ähm.
In diesem Fall ja der der BND mit einem Wunsch an einen Provider herangetreten war und das aber noch nicht,
einer tatsächliche, ein tatsächlicher Akt der Regierung war in diesem Sinne, ähm hatte der Betreiber dem dem Gezin äh jetzt dem G zehn Gremium darüber erstmal gar nichts zu erzählen.
Ja, also das leuchtet mir sogar ein, der Kontrollgremium der Regierung,
ich sag nicht, dass das falsch war, sich an die zuwenden, das war genau das Richtige, das zu tun, aber ähm wie gesagt, die die Bürokratie und die Struktur sehen das so jetzt erstmal, glaube ich, nicht vor.
Ähm aber dann wurden sie, wie gesagt, ins äh Kanzleramt geraten, geladen wurde gesagt, seid ihr wahnsinnig, ne? Wenn ihr dürft niemandem erzählen, dass ihr mit BND gesprochen habt und so und,
Das war also im äh Februar, äh am siebenundzwanzigsten Februar zweitausendneun,
Und dann ist einige Zeit gar nichts passiert. Langefeld sagt der BND hatte technische äh Umsetzungsschwierigkeiten.
Ähm klar, weil wenn die dann mal die Kapazitäten vom vom Dezex äh gehört haben, dann mussten die sich schon überlegen,
wie sie wie sie da ihr kleines Abschnorchelschnorchelchen dran halten. Und dann kam eine G zehn Anordnung.
Die einzelne Anbieter betraf aber bei weitem nicht alle, sagt er. Das war deutlich geringer als das, was zweitausendacht besprochen wurde.
Und,
Auf diesen ersten Anordnungen, die da zweitausendacht einen K eingingen, waren auch deutsche Anbieter drauf und innerdeutsche Leitungen,
zum Beispiel eine Leitung von Frankfurt nach Karlsruhe mit fünfundneunzig Prozent Deutschen verkehren.
Schöne Formulierung.
Ja? Ähm und.
Der Herr Landefeld sagt dann, na ja, wir waren ähm gleich, der der Ansicht, dass der sich dann eben an die Betreiber der Leitungen wenden soll und nicht an uns. Ja, das war von Anfang an der Streitpunkt und leuchtet aber natürlich auch ein, dass der BND,
ähm dahin geht, wo alles hingeht und lieber mit einer Partei ähm sprechen möchte.
Einer Partei Anordnung geben möchte, als jetzt mit einzelnen Betreibern zu sprechen, ja? Ähm.
Fazit der ganzen Geschichte, sagt er, die operieren da eigentlich so ein bisschen im rechtsfreien Raum. Also man kann eigentlich sagen,
das Internet ist ein ist ein rechtsfreier Raum an dieser Stelle.
So so, ich dachte, es sollte immer nicht der rechtsfreie Raum sein.
Ja, weil es einfach keine technischen Richtlinien gibt. Er sagt.
Zu den Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnungen. Mit denen die ja übrigens auch zu tun haben, ne? Oder ihr Internetprovider auch, wenn da eine TKÜ Anordnung auf einen Server kommt, dann ähm haben die natürlich damit zu tun.
Ähm dann sagt er, eine ähm da gibt es eine.
Er sagt das ja schön, das ist bis ins letzte Bit runter dokumentiert, wieder stattzufinden hat. Und bei G zehn gibt's gar nichts.
Und dann spricht er noch ein bisschen aus dem Nähkästchen geplaudert, dass ähm der BND die auf die Ansicht,
Pflege. Das Transitverkehre weitergegeben werden können. Also äh.
Du gehst voll, du hast ein ein Datenpaket, was von von Polen nach Holland geschickt wird, ähm durch den durch den Dezix,
und dann hängt da der BND dran und sagt, oh, das ist aber ein schönes Datenpaket, was machen wir denn jetzt damit? Ja, das tauschen wir einfach mal mit dem polnischen und mit dem Niederländischen Geheimdienst. Die haben ja so Schwierigkeiten, da dran zu kommen, ja? Das wäre also,
üblich. Und dann sagt er, das wäre, also würden die Techniker relativ offen drüber sprechen und das finde also nicht in Ordnung.
Und dann hat er noch eine sehr interessante Geschichte erzählt.
Wo er sagt, zweitausenddreizehn hat dann die Bundesnetzagentur mal eine Anhörung von Telekommunikationsunternehmen vorgenommen,
und hat einen Fragebogen an die Unternehmen verschickt, unter anderem so Fragen drauf, wie ähm betreibt ihr Unternehmen Überwachungseinrichtungen,
nach äh Paragraph fünf oder Paragraph acht G zehn Gesetz und,
dann hat das Bundeskanzleramt die Vizepräsidentin der Bundesnetzagentur angerufen und gesagt, ey seid ihr wahnsinnig? Die Unternehmen dürfen diese Fragen nicht beantworten. Die Bundesnetzagentur hatte gar nicht das Recht, diese Fragen zu stellen. Also.
Er hat im Prinzip jetzt nix erzählt, was man sich nicht ohnehin schon denken konnte. Da das nämlich ähm.
Dass, dass das eben da einfach getan wird,
operieren dann nicht in irgendeiner Form von von strengen strengen gesetzlichen Rahmen und gehen halt mit einer Maximalforderung da rein. Und es ist, denke ich, der der.
Dem Gerechtigkeitsempfinden und der Standhaftigkeit von Klaus Landefeld und dem Dezix dazu verdanken,
Dass da überhaupt noch in irgendeiner Form eine Einschränkung stattgefunden hat, so lächerlich die jetzt auch ist.
Und so ein schlechtes Gefühl eher jetzt da auch hat. Er sagte dann natürlich auch erzählt dir dann so ähnliche Geschichten wie der Nicholis Maril über die Gag-Orders in äh beim vor vielen Jahren beim Kongress erzählt hat, dass er sagt, ja ich wusste ja gar nicht, mit wem ich jetzt darüber sprechen darf.
Weil eigentlich ja heißt, wir dürfen man darf nur niemanden, noch nicht mal jemanden sagen, dass man mitm BND Kontakt hatte.
Ja
Das ist überhaupt das die die grundsätzliche Perversion dieses ganzen Geheimhaltungsspiralen, das hatten wir ja auch schon bei der Betrachtung der NSA äh Sache, nicht? Also dass Firmen da mit
Orders und so weiter auf Linie gebracht werden, niemand mehr irgendjemand was sagen darf und da sterben natürlich dann auch alle,
Kontrollen. Ich meine, wenn man schon irgendwie Überwachung betreibt, dann sollte man da einfach auch klar zu stehen und sagen, ja okay, machen wir, ist so,
findet statt. Ja, schreibt mir gar nicht ab, aber selbst das scheint ja irgendwie unmöglich zu sein.
Ja und vor allem interessant wär dann genommen, dann wäre natürlich auch schön, wenn wir als Bürger wüssten, in welchem Rahmen, ne, was sind denn da die rechtlichen.
Mal Bedingungen und wie das so stattfindet. Aber nein, aber nein.
Tja, sonst ist die Abschreckung eigentlich immer so wichtig, ne? Und hier irgendwie gar nicht. Macht eigentlich auch alles keinen Sinn.
Aber sehr schön, also eine sehr schöne Aussage ist, empfiehlt sich natürlich wie immer grundsätzlich ähm das Protokoll zu lesen. Ich habe jetzt nur eine Synopse der Synopse.
Protokolls äh hier mal von mir gegeben. Also auch hier gilt, ne, mal schauen, was andere dazu sagen.
Möchtest du zum nächsten Thema?
Mache ich gerne, mache ich gerne. Genau, denn wir müssen mal wieder über das Leistungsschutzrecht reden und ähm.
Überhaupt habe ich so den Eindruck, wird sich der Rest äh dieser Sendung so ein bisschen mit diesem sagenumwobenen Land beschäftigen, wo wir alle von Zeit zu Zeit auch mal,
Urlaub machen, aber froh sind, wenn wir nur kurz dort Urlaub machen, ja? Das Land absurdistan.
Und äh wir wissen ja alle, dass Leistungsschutzrecht
ist so ein richtiger äh Knaller eigentlich. Wieso ist so ein bisschen auch ein bisschen so ein Popstar, finde ich irgendwie äh in in absurdistan, also wenn man sich so das Land absurdes Zahn vorstellt, ja, dann wäre bestimmt so das Leistungsschutzrecht,
Es wäre so der Song für den Eurovision Song Contest, den Absurdistan dann so äh einsendet.
Das ganze Land einfach auch repräsentiert so ein bisschen. Den Eindruck habe ich immer so ein bisschen. Was hast du denn da ausgegraben?
Das war ein ein wunderschönes, also es gab jetzt ich ich glaube sogar vielleicht das erste.
Das erste Urteil zum Leistungsschutzrecht. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Ja
Aber ich glaube, es muss das Erste sein und es wird sein seinem seinen geistigen Vater sehr gerecht.
Dieser Fall ist, ist großartig. Dieser Fall ist köstlich. Ähm also eine Medienagentur.
Hat auf ihrer Website ein Foto veröffentlicht. Auf dieser Website werden auch gelegentlich mal Artikel veröffentlicht.
Diese Medienagentur hat damit aber das Urheberrecht einer
Fotoagentur verletzt, das ausschließliche Nutzungsrecht einer Fotoagentur äh verletzt. Ne, wie Nutzungsrecht, Verwertungsrecht oder was auch immer. Das war also das Bild gehörte, also die die Rechte an diesem Bild, hatte eine Fotoagentur,
und sie hatten das nicht von dieser Fotoagentur lizensiert, also eine klassische Lizenzverletzung, die diese Medienagentur da begangen hat.
Ja, das wird dann abgemahnt und fertig.
Genau, das hat dann auch ähm der die Fotoagentur gemacht und er hat ähm,
der Medienagentur geschrieben und hat äh Mitte zweitausendvierzehn eine Nachlizensierung für von für zweihundertvierzig Euro, fünfundsiebzig verlangt.
Schnäppchen.
Und in diesem Schreiben ähm in diesem Schreiben gab es dann einen Link.
Persönlichen Zugangscode, also es war so ein Link, wo dann so drinsteht, langer Hash, lala lahm,
Und da könnte man das Beweismittel abrufen, nämlich,
oder den Vorgang abrufen und in diesem Vorgang befand sich dann ein Screenshot von der bemängelten Seite. Und dieser Screenshot umfasst jetzt also den Artikel.
Und dass in diesen Artikel eingebettete Bild und war auf der Seite dieser Fotoagentur, wo sie also sagten, hier, ne, hat unsere Rechte verletzt, geht mal auf diese Seite, da könnt ihr das sehen, da ist der Vorgang dokumentiert und so, ne, dann könnt ihr das, könnt ihr das gucken,
So, jetzt jetzt hat also diese Fotoagentur auf ihrer Website ihr eigenes Foto gehabt und den Artikel.
Den die Medienagentur geschrieben hatte, in denen sie dieses Bild widerrechtlich eingebettet hatten. Und,
dann hat die ähm Medienagentur diese Nachlizenzierungsangebot da zur Kenntnis genommen, aber äh nicht angenommen.
Und hat stattdessen die Fotoagentur abgemahnt.
Weil die Fotoagentur ja auf ihrer Internetseite auf ihrem Server einen Screenshot hatte von ihrem Presseerzeugnis, nämlich diesem Artikel, in dem das wiederum das widerrechtliche, widerrechtlich eingefügt war, das Bild von dieser Fotoagentur.
Mit dem Argument Leistungsschutzrecht.
Genau, urheberrechtlich geschützter Inhalt, Inhalt unberechtigt öffentlich zugänglich gemacht. Und und hat.
Nun gut, also ist das schon explizit ein Bezugnahme auf das Leistungsschutzrecht gewesen in in dem Moment?
Ich habe mir jetzt die, ja, ja, schon. Ich habe mir die Paragrafen aber jetzt da nicht alle, alle nicht angeschaut. Wie gesagt, ich bin hier kein Anwalt. Meine Eltern haben mir ja gesagt, ich soll kein Jura studieren.
Nee, haben die echt? Haben die, ich wollte das eigentlich ganz gerne, aber meinen Eltern gesagt, nee, das nicht. Alles, alles, aber nicht dat.
Okay, jetzt hat also die Fotoagentur, dann keine Unterlassungserklärung abgegeben,
und dann hat das Landgericht Berlin einige Tage darauf eine einstweilige Verfügung erlassen.
Nochmal eine kurze Frage, diese URL war sozusagen nur so eine URL, aber ohne so einen HTTP Login, also es gab nicht so Passwort oder so, sondern es war nur so eine URL, die man nur dann abrufen konnte, wenn man diesen Link zugeschickt bekommen hatte, eigentlich.
Ja. Also.
Nicht so, dass es bei Google irgendwie im Index gelandet wäre oder so.
Nein, nein, nein, es war nicht öffentlich verlinkt. Ähm das ist,
Ich meine, das kannst du jetzt das nicht gut, das so zu machen, aber du kannst natürlich äh wenn du jetzt sagen wir mal zum Beispiel sagst, okay, du machst den den Link nur über HTPS zugänglich
und dann machst du ihn halt irgendwie möglichst obskur, ne. Gibst du irgendwie so ein Token dazu oder so ähm dann kannst du schon davon ausgehen, dass das jetzt nicht öffentlich ist. Also der wird,
Es müsste ja jemand um die Kenntnis davon zu erlangen, müsste ja jemand diese oder diese Tokens durch,
und wenn du die ausreichend ähm,
Wenn du dir ausreichend äh zufällig wählst und ausreichend lang und kein Direct Realisting machst, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass jemand das aufruft, äußerst gering.
Also das mache ich zum Beispiel, wenn ich irgendwie größere Dateien verschicken will, dann haue ich die halt ähm mache ich das so. Also dass ich halt irgendwie
jemandem sagt, hier ist der Link, eine HTPS-Link, dann ist halt ein langer, langer, langer Tauben dazwischen und so und dann,
nur dann gibt die Seite das raus und das ist theoretisch öffentlich und ungeschützt. Aber in der Praxis ist das halt ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr, sehr, sehr gering, dass da nochmal jemand anders draufkommt.
Und jetzt äh sagt also das ähm ähm,
Also das das die die einstweilige Verfügung, dieses dieses Landgerichts Berlin ist also sagt also der Medienagentur steht gegenüber der Fotoagentur ein Unterlassungsanspruch gemäß dem Paragraphen achtundsiebzig siebenundachtzig folgende siebenundneunzig,
und,
neunzehn A und jetzt siehst du, ich habe kein Jura studiert, das ist natürlich siebenundachtzig F und nicht siebenundachtzig Folgen. Ja, so eine siebenundachtzig F siebenundneunzig und hundertundneunzehn A des Urheberrechtsgesetzes zu, da auf der Webseite der Antragstellerin.
Also, der Medienagentur auch Artikel veröffentlicht wurden, handele es sich dabei um ein Presseerzeugnis, auf welche das Leistungsschutzrecht anwendbar sei.
Und dann sagen sie explizit ein Zugänglichmachen, liege auch dann vor, wer in der Inhalt nur über die Direktangabe der Ziel-URL, also außerhalb einer normalen Suchfunktion zugänglich ist.
Ähm.
Diese Entscheidung ist aus aus mehrerlei Hinsicht ähm kritisch und wird so vermutlich keinen Bestand haben, dass wir denn.
Sie haben nicht wirklich geprüft, ob die Medienagentur ein äh Presseerzeugnis verbreitet hat. Ähm denn
Es müsste dazu eine redaktionell technische Festlegung journalistischer Beiträge vorliegen,
als überwiegend verlagstypisch anzusehen ist und nicht überwiegend der Eigenwerbung dient, dass das bei einer Medienagentur der Fall ist, ist natürlich äußerst unwahrscheinlich.
Und.
Entscheidende Fehler dieser Entscheidung ist, nach Paragraph siebenundachtzig G Urwahlrechtsgesetz ist das öffentlichen, ist die öffentliche Zugänge durch,
meine Güte, ist die öffentliche zugängliche Machung von Presseerzeugnissen oder Teilen hiervon
zulässig, explizit zulässig, wenn sie nicht durch gewerbliche Anbieter von Suchmaschinen oder gewerbliche Anbieter von Diensten erfolgt, die Inhalte entsprechend aufbereiten. Und diese
Diese Abmahninfoseite der Fotoagentur war ja jetzt weder eine äh gewerbliche Suchmaschine noch,
eine äh entsprechende Aufbereitung. Ja, also das war ein Fehlentscheidung, würde ich's vermuten,
Aber wie gesagt, ich bin kein Anwalt.
Ja, aber ist schon interessant, dass gleich so die erste oder zumindest eine der ersten Entscheidungen zum Leistungsschutzrecht sozusagen sämtliche Sicherheitsklauseln, die da jetzt reingehämmert wurden, um das Ding nicht komplett
äh wie so ein Feuerwerkskörper im Raum durch die Gegend schießen zu lassen, sofort nicht gegriffen haben. Finde ich immer sehr beruhigend.
Ein bisschen wie Richtervorbehalt so. Ja, na ja, ja, theoretisch kann da ja was passieren, aber wenn, ja, wir haben da ja Richter vorbehalt und wir wissen ja, wie
alle so drauf sind und so, da kann ja nichts passieren,
Ja, ja. So und hier halt auch so, naja, ist ja nur, wenn du eine Suchmaschine und nur, wenn gewerblich und dann kann, das kann ich ja überhaupt nicht betreffen. Und das kann Bock gar keine Kollateralschäden geben. Zack, bumm, gleich, erste Entscheidung, alles äh für die Cuts.
Ja, aber ist doch, aber ich meine.
Muss man so sehen, ne, wenn wenn da der eine, der eine ist ein ist ein Abmahner, okay, Fotoagentur ist jetzt auch wieder so eine Sache, ne. Ähm.
Ich kenne die, ich habe mich jetzt nicht schlau gemacht, welche Fotoagentur das ist und in diesem Fall hat sie auch recht, also ich meine, das ist eine Fotoagentur, die verdient,
ihr Geld und ernährt Fotografen dadurch, dass sie Fotos lizensiert und wenn dann eine Medienagentur in ihrer äh in ihrer Darstellung diese Bilder nutzt, ähm,
eine Abmahnung oder eine Lizenzforderung zu schicken, ist glaube ich wahrscheinlich schon dann im Rahmen des Gesetzes legitim, ja, dass.
Ja, sicher, klar, also ich meine, das ist ja deren Job sozusagen, so einen Kram zu lizensieren und wenn jemand das halt nicht lizensiert und veröffentlicht, dann ne, also ich meine, das,
kann man zwar scheiße finden, aber das ist nun mal Sinn einer Lizenz, also das,
Der erste Schritt war sozusagen nachvollziehbar. Das Interessante ist, dass sie quasi nur ein Beleg liefern, den möglichst einfach konsumierbar äh machen wollten und dass die Medienagentur dann eben gleich die Maximalkeule ausgepackt hat und gesagt hat, die äh ihr schickt
Beweise, ihr äh ihr veröffentlicht ja ein Presseerzeugnis. Ja, das ist ja ungefähr so, als ob man eine
so ein so ein Zeitungs äh Schnipsel äh fotokopiert den irgendwie äh äh einer einer Zeitung äh vorhält und sagt,
äh hier äh falsche Tatsachenbehauptungen, was auch immer und die anderen irgendwie äh verklagen, ja, dass man sozusagen dann äh einen Ausschnitt irgendwo in einen Brief gelegt hat und sozusagen mit dem Argument, man man würde ja jetzt selber hier anfangen, das irgendwie
zu vertreiben, ja?
Ja, also das ist äh wie gesagt, das ist ähm das ist schon sehr amüsant, was da passiert ist, aber herzlichen Glückwunsch an den Anwalt, der das geschafft hat, weil das das wird so nicht nochmal passieren.
Nein, Absurdistan ist das völlig normal.
Erzählen?
Ja, auch direkt aus äh absurdistan ist ja die Personal äh Personalie, die die Bundesregierung aufgerufen hat, ähm denn die.
Bundes äh Ministerium für Wirtschaft hat sich,
ein Beauftragten für digitale Ökonomie zugelegt. Das ist äh schön, ja, weil dann ist ja mal jemand äh zuständig.
Und die Wahl fiel äh durch Herrn Gabriel, sieht man Gabriel, ja? Unser Wirtschaftsminister äh auf keinen geringeren als Dieter,
Borney,
Da fängt man schon ein bisschen schwer an zu atmen, weil das ist einfach, ich meine, was was erwartet man von so einem Beauftragten, eines eines,
ähm an das Ministeriums. Man man erwartet, dass es jemand ist, der halt die,
Gesamtsituation aufnimmt, interpretiert ansprechbar ist und zwischen den beteiligten Interessenpartnern äh vermitteln. Nun ist Herr Gorni leider
eher äh bekannt als, ja, klares Mitglied und auch eben öffentlicher Lobbyist, der Musikindustrie.
Über Jahre gewesen, der auch ziemlich unverrückbar äh in einem bestimmten argumentativen Lager äh eingesperrt äh war und ist
so
Und eigentlich immer für Dinge ähm geworben hat, die ja vor allem auch wie Netzpolitik org schön zusammengestellt hat. Äh alle ziemlich äh
Flops waren. Also fast nichts von dem, was so äh von Herrn Gorni vertreten wurde in den letzten Jahren, äh hat in irgendeiner Form,
tatsächlich den Weg ins Gesetzesblatt geschafft. Kann man so sagen.
Wenn dann nur kurz, ne?
Ja und bin dann nur sehr kurz.
Man muss halt wissen, diese Beauftragtenrolle beim beim beim Ministerium, das ist ähm ein ein Ehrenamt, ne. Das ist ähm,
Ein Ehrenamt für ein Wirtschaftslobbyisten, der in in diesem Bereich äh digitale Ökonomie natürlich auch für kreative und digitale Ökonomie natürlich ganz ganz eindeutig ähm also der Mann, das ist,
Da ist der da ist der Fokus sehr auf Ökonomie, ne? Dieser Mann ist weder besonders kreativ noch besonders digital.
Aber ähm er vertritt halt eine eine Industrie, die relativ relativ viel Geld mit ähm.
Mit mit den kreativen Leistungen anderer Menschen verdient. Und ähm,
Was Netzpolitik org da mal so ein bisschen zusammengetreten. Also der Gonny, der der geistert ja schon länger darum, der war, meine ich auch in der Enquete-Kommission äh Internet und digitale,
ähm.
Er ist äh öfter mal bei also immer mal wieder macht er von sich reden. Das ist auch so ein bisschen so ein hemdsärmliger Typ, der dann irgendwie äh so mit so Sachen,
zitiert wird, wo du auch denkst, äh ja,
Also wir gehen mal zweitausendacht äh los. Da ging es ja um äh in Frankreich und England los, wo man gesagt hat, wir wollen Warnhinweise ähm an die Nutzer verschicken und ähm Internetanschlüsse abschalten.
Und da sagte äh das ginge ja dabei jetzt nicht um eine permanente, flächendeckende Überwachung der Internetnutzung oder gar um Zensur.
Ähm.
Nachgewiesen Urheberrechtsverletzungen sollten die Provider einfach nur ihre AGBs anwenden. Also er setzt die Interessen der Wirtschaft, des Wirtschaftszweigs, den er vertritt, eben
höher als das Interesse des oder das Recht des Bürgers auf äh den Zugang zu zum Internet und sagt also, das wäre also,
völlig in Ordnung, wenn ähm,
die Provider eben hier so eine Art private Rechtsdurchsetzung für seine Industrie vornehmen. Das ist völlig in Ordnung
ging es um das um die ne? Wir erinnern uns alle die gute Zensursula von der Leyen.
Sagte also äh wir bräuchten jetzt einen, wir bräuchten jetzt also Stoppschilder im Internet, ne,
sagten ja schon alle, alles klar, dass ähm wenn ihr das jetzt macht, dann ähm,
dann wissen wir, was als nächstes kommt, ne? Dann sperrt ihr alles Mögliche und natürlich der an erster Front dabei und sagte, ja Stoppschilder, gute Idee. Äh dazu gehört,
auch der Schutz des geistigen Eigentums. Ja, also das war natürlich klar, dass er dann da auch irgendwie Sperrlisten für für unbeliebte äh Peer-to-Peer-Sharing-Seiten haben wollte. Ähm
dann sagt er gleichzeitig, im gleichen Jahr noch zweitausendneun, wollte er so einen flensburger Punktesystem ganz gerne haben für Internetnutzer.
Wenn der User illegale Handlungen im Internet vornimmt, soll er dafür Punkte bekommen. Und ab einer gewissen Anzahl,
ist dann beispielsweise die Bandbreite reduziert, reduziert oder der Internetzugang im Haus, wird für drei Monate gesperrt, also Führerscheinen hinzu, ne?
Wenn du dich nicht nach unseren und es geht immer nur, immer nur um seine Industrie da, ne? Also ist der hat da wirklich ähm sehr äh das also ein Experte, ja, dem man auch mal raten könnte,
sich in anderen Bereichen ein bisschen kundig zu machen.
So so ein Punktesystem fände ich ja eigentlich generell mal ganz äh gut, was so dumme Bemerkungen äh betrifft. Ja, also dass man sozusagen,
für so dumme Bemerkungen dann auch einfach mit entsprechenden Punkten belegt wird und wenn man dann irgendwie fünfzehn Punkte zusammen hat, ja?
Die verfallen dann vielleicht so teilweise dann so nach ein, zwei Jahren dann auch wieder, dann darf man sich so ein bisschen berappeln. So ab und zu darf man auch mal auf die Kacke hauen, aber wenn man einfach die ganze Zeit kontinuierlich immer nur auf die Kacke haut, dann ist dann halt irgendwann,
Schluss. Wär doch mal was, oder?
Ne, dann sagte er nochmal, zweitausendelf hatte er den Gedanken immer noch, sagt er,
Würde das ja so machen wie die Franzosen, aber das ist derzeit in Deutschland politisch nicht durchsetzbar. Äh aber sagt er so, ja nicht für immer, nur für ein paar Wochen, ein bisschen Internet weg. Das würden die schon merken. Was er natürlich
da vergisst ist, dass das H-Dopi-Gesetz in Frankreich ja auch irgendwie, glaube ich, nur ein einziges Mal irgendwie zur Anwendung gekommen ist und da irgendwie Milliarden
oder Millionen verschlungen hat aber das war ja Steuerzahler Geld das ist ja das sind ja dann wenigstens keine,
vermeintlichen theoretischen Einbußen der Musikindustrie.
Und zweitausendzwölf, als Debatte um acta losging, ne, große Proteste gegen äh des
da war er natürlich sofort mit großem Nachdruck dabei und sagte, wir brauchen eine zukunftsorientierte Reform
des äh des Urheberrechts um dessen Schutz im digitalen Zeitalter in Angriff zu nehmen und war auf jeden Fall für äh solche,
für solche Vereinbarungen, ne? Also das ist ein, das ist schon ganz klar, äh Westgeistes oder für welche.
Interessen er da kompromisslos mit Maximalforderungen eintritt. Und dann ist er natürlich auch vielleicht im Wirtschaftsministerium gar nicht ähm,
so falsch.
Aufbewahrt, ne? Also ich meine, Wirtschaftsministerium ist dafür da, dass äh irgendwie so Industriezweige irgendwie,
sich bereichern und ähm dafür, da ist er natürlich dann auch gut aufgehoben.
Ja, ich weiß ja nicht, ob das immer alles wirklich so gut ist für die äh Musikindustrie. Also wenn ich so in in der Musikindustrie wäre, weiß ich nicht, ob das jetzt wirklich der Weg ist mit äh mit dem ich so die Branche voranbringen wollen würde.
Ja, also das ist.
Wenn man sich die wenn man sich mal so Wirtschaft anschaut, ne? Es gibt immer so Wirtschafts- oder Geschäftsmodelle, die gehen über über viele Jahre oder Jahrzehnte gut und dann äh sterben sie einen unweigerlichen Tod
Ähm und äh ich meine, ich bin im Ruhrgebiet geboren. Ich kann da wirklich ein ein Steigerlied von singen,
und.
Ähm die ähm dann da musst du eben am Ende muss, brauchst du eben Leute, die da irgendwie nochmal richtig ähm Rabatz machen, ne.
Schön finde ich bei ähm bei beim Musikmarkt DE ist ein,
Berufungsschreiben aufgetaucht, das angeblich eben Gabriel an den geschrieben haben soll, wo es dann so sagt würde, Gabriel schreibt,
Wir sind uns ja darüber einig, dass die Kultur- und Kreativwirtschaft von der Digitalisierung besonders betroffen ist, ihre Innovation und Produkte sind einerseits
direkter Treiber wesentlicher gesellschaftlicher und ökonomischer Veränderung, die weit über die elf Teilmärkte der Branche hinausgehen. Gleichzeitig verändert die Digitalisierung aber auch die Geschäftsmodelle der Branche. Von der Kultur- und Kreativwirtschaft
ausgehende Innovation berühren und prägen dabei auch andere Wirtschaftszweige und wirtschaftliche Erscheinungen wie etwa Industrie vier Punkt null,
kreative und digitale Ökonomie.
Eine Verzahnung und Vermittlung der bestehenden Initiativen und Strategien der Kultur- und Kreativwirtschaft einerseits mit der digitalen Agenda und der innovativen Digitalisierung der Wirtschaft erscheint mir daher erforderlich.
Ich freue mich, dass Sie sich bereit erklärt haben, mich bei dieser Aufgabe als Experte beratend zu unterstützen,
bestimmet sie sie zum Beauftragten für kreative und digitale Ökonomie. Tja, ich weiß nicht, also es ist, es ist klar, in welche Richtung Gabriel da den Tanker äh steuern möchte.
Es ist auch klar, dass das irgendwie nicht so wirklich die Zukunft ist, wenn aber, also nicht die wirkliche Zukunft,
aber in absurdistan wird das noch so ein bisschen Zukunft bleiben und man muss sich jetzt auch nicht einbilden, dass so ein nicht äh schon vorher die ganze Zeit
an Gabriels Ohr gehangen hat. Deswegen frage ich mich eigentlich vielmehr, warum der dem überhaupt da jetzt noch so ein so ein Posten gibt. Ähm,
was ja dann eine offizielle Rolle ist.
Ähm wo er doch ohnehin seit seit vielen Jahren da eben inoffiziell eine selbstverständlich als Lobbyist unterwegs ist, ne. Also das ist ähm,
Das das soll wahrscheinlich so eine so ein Signal sein oder so.
Aber an wen?
Das Signal lautet, ich habe das, ich weiß leider jetzt nicht, welcher wie der Artikel, wer den Artikel geschrieben hatte, aber wir verlinken den, der hatte einen sehr schönen Titel, ähm der Bock ist jetzt Beauftragter für Gartenbau.
Super. Oh man. Ja.
Aber wenn ich mal, ich will jetzt mal ganz kurz, ne, weil ich ja immer mich bemühe, denen die andere Seite auch mit zu würdigen.
Ähm wenn.
Du als Wirtschaftsministerium ein auf digitale, die digitale Ökonomie.
Da irgendwie gesetzlich ändern möchtest und dass das Land für die für die Zukunft einstellen möchtest, ne? Dann musst du dir natürlich.
Experten aus diesem Bereich holen. Und selbstverständlich kannst du dir da nicht.
Fachfremde Menschen holen, ähm die dann Entscheidungen treffen, die das Potenzial haben,
einen sehr großen Wirtschaftszweig nachhaltig zu stören, ja? Ähm.
Ebenso wie ich, jetzt, was weiß ich, ab und zu mal zu Fragen der IT-Sicherheit befragt werde, ähm wenn es zum Beispiel jetzt auch bei dem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz darum geht, sich da gesetzlich einzumischen,
ähm werden dann natürlich auch die äh Betroffenen unternehmen oder deren Sicherheitsvertreter befragt.
Was sie von diesem Gesetz halten und.
So wird das eben auch in Wirtschaftsfragen getan. Ähm man muss eben als Zivilgesellschaftliche Organisation sich dann immer sehr bemühen darauf zu achten, dass die die.
Grund und Bürger und Verbraucherrechte da nicht ähm unter die Räder kommen,
und da werden wir jetzt zum Glück auch regelmäßig gefragt, aber es ist schon klar, dass äh wenn du jetzt irgendwie im Wirtschaftsministerium äh fragst, was weiß ich, in der Abteilung äh,
Montanindustrie, wer da die Berater sind, ähm,
vorausgesetzt es gäbe jetzt eine Abteilung Mantanindustrie, dann sind das selbstverständlich schon Vertreter der betroffenen Industrie.
Ja, aber ich meine dieser äh aber ist denn dieser, ist dieser, ich kann, ist der, wird denn dieser in dieser Musikindustrie eigentlich gefeiert? Für seine für sein Engagement? Das ist mir irgendwie auch unklar.
Ich meine, der Typ ist doch auch so ein bisschen Elefant im Porzellanladen.
Das weiß ich nicht, ich kenne die Musikindustrie nicht. Also.
Also ich meine ich würde mich auch ein bisschen schämen, ja, für für so einen Vertreter in der Öffentlichkeit.
Ja, du kannst dir deine Vertreter ja nicht aussuchen, ne, so wie wir jetzt äh mitbluten müssen für Fefe, muss die Musik,
eben mitbluten für für und müssen wir alle mitbluten für Angela Merkel, die Griechen auch, ja, also kannst du immer nicht.
Alle bluten.
Kannst du dir nicht, kannst du dir nicht aussuchen.
Bluten für die Netzpolitik.
Es ist ähm es wäre.
Ich finde das nicht so schlimm, wenn sich ein also schlimmer, wie sagt man,
jetzt muss ich dieses ein komplizierter Satz nicht gerade sagen will. Also es ist nicht schlimm, dass ähm Sigmar Gabriel sich auch Dieter Gorny als Berater holt.
Schlimm ist, dass er so wie es aussieht, ihm kein nennenswertes Gegengewicht,
bietet. Ja, es wäre also völlig, völlig sinnvoll, wenn er sagen würde, okay, ich nehme mir den, ich nehme mir den Gorni, ich nehme mir irgendwie so ein, sagen wir mal, den, den,
den Leonard Dobusch von der immer mit Urheberrecht auseinandersetzt, der wirklich Ahnung davon hat.
Ja.
Und der aber natürlich auch 'ne sehr Nutzerzentrierte Perspektive hat und dann nehme ich mir noch so 'n so 'n so 'n Vollpiraten dazu oder irgendwie so einen aus der aus der Economy oder so.
Voll Pirat.
Ja, irgendwie sowas, ja, dann Peter Sunde, ja, holst dir Peter Sohne, Lena Dobrisch und Dieter Gorne. Ich glaube, Peter Sohn, ne? Und
Leonardo wären so ein so ein grobes Gegengewicht zum und dann lässt du die beiden da mal was ausdiskutieren.
Und dann sagst du halt so, ihr müsst euch jetzt hier einig werden, ihr könnt euch jetzt nicht das wäre natürlich schön, also so ähnlich wie zu sagen, ne, nicht nur Fefe lesen, äh sondern eben auch mal ein paar andere Sachen
so seinen Input mal.
Diversifizieren, um dann eben alles zu erkennen und dann irgendwie eine vernünftige Entscheidung zu treffen, ne? Das würde man sich ja von unseren Politikern wünschen. Bisher sieht man das eben bei Gabriel nicht
Der scheint aber auch sowieso gegen Input ja relativ immun zu sein, wie wir das schon in den letzten Sendungen ähm ein bisschen behandelt hatten.
Ja, na ja, vielleicht bewirbt er sich einfach als Kanzler in absurdistan, da hätte er auf jeden Fall gute Chancen.
Na ja, er ist ja schon Vizekanzler.
Da aber nur Vizekanzler. Aber er will ja Kalifan-Schälle des Kalifen werden, aber das klappt irgendwie nicht.
Ihr glaubt ja nicht, hatte ja schon aufgegeben, aber also.
Ich wollte das nur noch mal so ein bisschen einordnen, dass also ich meine, wenn man sich in wenn man mal in die Enquete-Kommission geschaut hat, ne, was da alles für für Gespenster drin rumgerannt sind, ne. Ähm,
neben den natürlich hier auf äh,
Seiten der der Netzgemeinde oder dem Verbraucher sehr herausgestellt und sehr geehrte äh Mitglieder, wie äh Konstanze oder äh Markus,
Da könnte man an der Stelle nochmal die, die Folge übrigens empfehlen, die wir mit äh Konstanze gemacht haben zum zur zum Ende der Enquete-Kommission. Sollen wir dir empfehlen, Tim?
Das können wir auf jeden Fall empfehlen. Das war ein schöner äh Rückblick und auch eine interessante Einordnung, was grad so die Personalien äh betrifft, die sich da so engagieren und welchen sind.
Gut, also dann dann empfehle ich hiermit ähm unsere eigene Folge, die mit Konstanzen, das war nur den Link raus.
Ja. Na ja, also unsere eigenen Folgen kann man immer empfehlen.
Die sind sowieso relativ empfehlenswert. Also gemessen.
Meisten zumindest.
An dem an den an äh gemessen an den Themen, die wir behandeln, wo wir in der Regel Sachen nicht empfehlen, sind unsere Folgen sehr zu empfehlen.
Genau.
So während wir tippen, sind wir durch mit äh Herrn.
Sind wir durch, oder? Ja.
Sind wir durch, ja. Oh, jetzt ist das Leck wieder da, liebe Hörer und.
Ja, wir haben ein bisschen. Das klingt so ein bisschen, als wären wir sowieso so leicht sediert, als hätten wir jetzt hier beim äh Kiffin teilgenommen in Berlin. Haben wir aber nicht, weil wir waren nicht da.
Wie war der denn? Ich war nicht da, wie war.
War auch nicht da, keine Ahnung. Leute saßen im Park und haben gekifft, glaube ich und die Bullen saßen drum herum und sonst.
Waren die Bullen da. Ich hatte es nicht. Ich habe keine Berichte.
Ja, ich habe irgendwo ein Foto gesehen, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich hatte auch noch nicht mal die Zeit, mich da groß mit zu beschäftigen, aber es fand irgendwie statt und Politiker waren.
Alles wie immer.
Ja, alles wie immer. So, aber wir wir haben zur Zeit nur den Wind, nur etwas Wind davon bekommen und schauen jetzt ein bisschen verstrahlt hier in unsere Skype-Röhre und äh haben Leck.
Also wenn der wenn der Kiff in äh wenn der Kiffin eine Wolke schafft, die die bis zu mir kommt, dann haben die echt gekifft.
Genau, aber äh ja, der Kiff-In findet jetzt irgendwie im BMWI statt und da rauchen sie auch definitiv irgendwas, von dem wir keine Ahnung haben. Ähm ja,
So ist das,
Gut, äh wenden wir uns äh der internationalen Politik äh zu. Die gibt's ja auch noch, ist ja nicht alles immer nur in Deutschland, sondern ähm,
Im Ausland gibt's mal wieder ordentlich äh Panik, wegen dieser Hacker, von dem man immer mehr hört, ne, weil die sind ja ganz schlimm, ganz furchtbar, gefährlich und da muss irgendwie auch unbedingt mal was gegen getan werden.
Die US-Regierung möchte gerne einen Erlass gegen das Cyberangriffe haben. Das ist so.
Den Song einspielen, der hält auch ewig, oder?
Hast du den auf den Knopf? Dann ich freue mich immer, den zu hören.
Ja, den können wir ja nochmal nach äh werfen. Ich denke so bei bei jeder Sendung, wo es irgendwie genug wo mindestens fünfmal sinnlos äh das der Begriff Cyber gesagt wurde oder dreimal, dann kann man ihn bringen. Gucken wir mal, wer vielleicht noch dazukommt.
Es ist, es ist hier.
Wir sehen das hier übrigens auch mit dem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz. Das will sich ja eigentlich auch so ein bisschen dem dem Cyber-Thema äh annähern. Ähm auch wenn es da größtenteils sich mit, mit anderen Themen beschäftigt. Ähm.
Obama hat jetzt ein Exekutiverlass äh äh erlassen. Ähm Executive Order. Ähm.
Und sagt, äh die Verantwortlichen für Cyber-Antacken-Attacken möchte er mit Sanktionen belegen.
Ähm die ähm vom US-Finanzministerium verhängt werden können. Also ähm könnte jetzt.
Könnte man zum Beispiel dann Content einfrieren und ähm Ähnliches. Interessant eigentlich,
Also dass sie, das sind halt so Maßnahmen, die du gegen gegen internationalen Terrorismus und gegen äh Putin äh erhebst, ne? Also Finanzsanktionen gegen Länder, ähm die sich daran beteiligen.
Und konnten einzufrieren oder so, das sind ja schon sehr interessante äh Maßnahmen. Ähm.
Ich frage mich, ganz ehrlich, immer noch, wie er denn meint, feststellen zu können, wer die Hacker sind.
Aber das muss er sich dann noch selber, ähm das muss er dann irgendwie selber für sich klären. Also es ist so ein es ist so ein.
Bin mir immer nicht so ganz sicher. Also er sagt jetzt die Fälle, die er behandelt ist oder die Fälle, auf die das anzuwenden ist seien, sollen sein,
Angriff auf wichtige Infrastruktur, wie Strom und Wasserversorgung, Diebstahl von Bank und Kreditkarteninformationen und Entwendung von Industriegeheimnissen.
Mhm.
Also im Prinzip all das, was die NSA vorbereitet oder tut.
Ja
Hm? Und er droht damit eben sowohl einzelnen Hackern als auch Unternehmen,
davon, die von den Angriffen profitieren, also noch nicht mal unbedingt, dass sie die ausführen, sondern dass sie die profitieren. Da sieht er auch schon, damit adressiert er, glaube ich, schon so dieses
einerseits die die das Atributionsproblem bei Cyberangriffen und andererseits eben auch seine Bereitschaft da ohne ähm.
Ohne Beweise.
Sanktionen einzuleiten. Anders ist ja dieser Begriff, äh wer davon profitiert wird, äh fertig gemacht. Ähm das ist ja so dieses,
Ding, ne? Verschwörungstheorie. Äh wir hauen jetzt drauf, äh das das waren doch bestimmt die und wenn nicht, dann hauen wir jetzt trotzdem drauf, weil die haben's jetzt oder so. Interessant.
Die Falschen. Äh kann nur die Richtigen treffen, ne.
Ja, ich meine so dieser diese Ausweitung auch des des Zugriffs auf so internationale Güter, die auch vielleicht nicht unmittelbar so auf den äh im eigenen äh Verfügungsbereich liegen. Ich weiß nicht, inwiefern das jetzt hier so international gedacht ist oder ich meine die die.
Nur international. Also das er hat sogar spezifisch genannt, China, Russland, Nordkorea und Iran.
Hm, ja, Neuseeland muss er da glaube ich auch noch mit einbeziehen, weil äh da haben sie ja gerade hier irgendwie die Kohle von äh Kimble jetzt irgendwie beschlagnahmt
den Artikel habe ich leider nicht ganz zu Ende gelesen, das war irgendwie, weiß nicht. Ich äh lenke jetzt grade aber so ein bisschen ab so, aber ne, auch so so Domains beschlagnahmen, hatten wir schon so ein äh paar Mal, ja, dass einfach mal so Domains, die so,
was weiß ich, wo Botnetze äh drunter laufen oder die aus anderen Gründen so und die halt von amerikanischen Unternehmen geführt werden. Die werden dann halt auch mal schnell so konfisziert, also das ist immer wieder so ein
so ein Problem, dass ja auch die USA einen unglaublichen Zugriff hat auf die ganze
Netzinfrastruktur, weil einfach so viele Unternehmen in den USA für die Aufrechterhaltung der Infrastruktur,
zuständig sind, also seitens Provider, den es Provider et cetera, Hoster aller Art. Ja.
Andererseits muss er sich natürlich auch um dieses äh um dieses Order umzusetzen.
Ähm siehst du natürlich, was äh braucht er ja irgendwie so eine was was jetzt gerade.
Also das das Wichtige der wichtige Begriff ist natürlich im Moment äh Fred Intelligence, ne. Das ist so gerade das Passwort in der Security Community und da ist er natürlich auch äh dran, dass er sagt, wir brauchen jetzt einen,
Integration Center.
Wo wir dann eben auch unsere Fähigkeiten erhöhen ähm diese,
Angriffe aufzuklären. Also das,
hat in einigen der äh Snowden-Dokumente und vor allem in in dem Bereich dieser Sony-Angriffe ähm auch eine Rolle gespielt, dass die USA gesagt haben, wir,
wissen, dass es von Nordkorea ausging. Aber wir können die Beweise nicht öffentlich vorbringen.
Die Vermutung damals war, dass sie, hat er, hoffentlich kriege ich das jetzt geographisch richtig zusammen, dass Nordkorea eigentlich nur eine Internetleitung hat.
Schöner.
Und die geht durch ähm die geht durch ähm.
China.
China, ne,
oder durch Südkoreaner, eins von beiden müssen sie, sie können ja nur äh durch eins von diesen beiden Ländern, aber dabei da Südkorea eigentlich nur noch Wasser um sich herum hat, ist wahrscheinlich wie durch China gegangen. Nee, es gibt da oben noch äh,
eine kleine Grenze mit Russland.
Russland, ja. Aber das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Also soweit ich weiß, sind sie nur über China connected, aber was weiß ich.
Okay, ich habe kann mich da leider nicht mehr dran erinnern. Aber da waren dann, da da stand natürlich die ach doch genau, natürlich. Also die die USA also so wunderschöne Verschwörungstheorie. Genau, die Kabel geht durch China.
Und die Chinesen,
haben ja wahrscheinlich Monitoring da dran und gucken können die können zumindest auf die auf den Traffic gucken.
Ob sie es getan haben ist eine andere Sache, aber die die Theorie geht so, dass die NSA oder die Amis, sagen wir mal, sagen wir einfach die Amis.
Überwachungsinfrastruktur der Chinesen gehackt haben.
Und damit Zugriff auf die auf den Internet-Traffic der Nordkoreaner hatten.
Und deswegen den Angriff einwandfrei atribuieren konnten.
Weil sie halt gesagt haben, okay, ging zwar durch irgendwie Anonymisierung und Tor, aber ähm wir konnten Traffic Correlation machen und das kam also
Nordkorea, aber deswegen konnten die Amis natürlich nicht sagen, woher sie das wussten, weil dann hätten sie ja zugeben müssen, dass sie die Chinesen gehackt haben und.
Die Chinesen hätten,
zugegeben, dass sie Zugriff oder hätten damit zugegeben, dass die Chinesen Zugriff auf die Nordkoreaner haben. Und deswegen haben alle einfach nur den den Mund gehalten. So gilt die, so geht die wunderschöne Verschwörungstheorie. Ich habe sie noch offen.
Ich habe sie noch auf Kette bekommen. Da freue ich mich jetzt drüber. Ähm aber jetzt sagen wir mal so ein bisschen.
So ein bisschen in alles verloren, weil ich schon wieder in den schönen Häkchengeschichten.
Ja ja, wir gleiten ab.
Aber natürlich haben sie ähm hat haben die USA in diesem Fall ähm schon.
Ordentliches Wissen gehabt und sie schicken sich jetzt an noch mehr dazu dafür zu bekommen. Und die Sanktionen, von denen sie da sprechen, sind sicherlich nicht, nicht so übel, wie das, was sie aufbauen werden,
um äh Atribuidierungen vornehmen zu können und diese Sanktionen dann auch tatsächlich erheben zu können.
Und ähm das wird dann nochmal übel. Also ich meine,
nicht ganz so schlimm oder der liest nicht ganz so dramatisch wie das wie die US-Geheimdienste und die US-Regierung ihn dann wieder interpretieren werden. Das wird sicherlich nochmal.
Ganz spannend, was daraus kommen wird.
So, sehr viel mehr kann man dazu nicht sagen, oder?
Also Executive Order ist halt so ein so ein Ermächtigungsgesetz, ne, also Chefsache. Bin mal gespannt, was da kommen wird.
Gut, gehen wir mal wieder zurück nach Deutschland.
Ja, kommen wir jetzt mal zu den, zu den Kurzmeldungen. Das Gesetz zum Routerzwang ist auf dem Weg. Ähm natürlich,
das Gesetz gegen den Routerzwang ist auf dem Weg und äh wie nicht anders zu erwarten war, protestieren jetzt in Stellungnahmen jene Provider, die den Routerzwang ausüben,
allen voran die Kabelnetzbetreiber, die dann ähm in ihrer Stellungnahme so schöne Sätze haben wie
das Kabelmodem filtert die für den jeweiligen Nutzer bestimmten Daten heraus und entschlüsselt sie, während andere Daten verworfen werden. Das stimmt. Ähm
über diese Kabelnetze ist Internet ist Internet im Prinzip wie Funk, Internet. Also ist beim beim Mobilfunk,
gerät nicht anders, ne? Die mein Handy ist prinzipiell in der Lage alle ähm Signale zu empfangen, aber die meisten Signale, die es empfangen kann, sind eben für das Handy äh bedeutungs und wertlos, weil sie.
Verschlüsselt sind. Aber du kannst zum Beispiel ähm so Pain-Request und so kannst du ja alles sehen, ja? Und das Handy verwirft halt alles oder das Baseband des Handys verwirft alles ähm was für das Handy selber äh,
für diese Identität nicht notwendig ist,
und deswegen gibt's auch ein Baseball, ich hatte es in einer älteren Folge schon mal erklärt, dass man sagt, okay, diesen Teil möchte man so ein bisschen von dem,
Android-Geraffel und so weiter trennen, damit wenigstens da unten auf der Ebene nichts schief geht. Und genau dieses Argument bringen jetzt die Kabel äh Netzbetreiber, dass sie sagen.
Erst das Kabelmodium als Netzabschlussgerät ähm ermöglicht im Zusammenspiel mit der Gegenstelle, den äh das Termin, also das das Ding am anderen Ende. Die Bereitstellung der individuellen Dienste für den Endkunden,
das Kabelmodell erfordert deshalb zwingend eine gerätespezifische Kabelnetzbetreiber individuelle konfigurationsfirmen, woher um die Dienste gegenüber dem Endkunden erbringen zu können, wofür sie eigentlich, wofür sie eigentlich Angst haben, ist ähm,
an dem Kabel irgendwie rumfuchtelt und der Mist macht. Diese Angst ist aber unbegründet, wie wir im Mobilfunkmarkt sehen. Da ist ja das gleiche Problem, aber wir dürfen ja trotzdem wir haben ja freie Wahl unserer Telefone.
Und in den USA, äh wo der äh Zugang zu,
Kabel äh der vor der Internetzugang über Kabel äh Fernsehen sehr viel verbreiteter ist
ist es zum Beispiel so, dass die Anbieter natürlich 'ne freie Wahl lassen, welchen Router man nimmt und haben dann so Listen, wo dann eben, was weiß ich, Time Runner sagt, hier folgende
Haben wir geprüft, die könnt ihr ruhig kaufen und bei allem anderen geben wir keine keine Garantie. Aber dass sie äh sagen, man könnte,
sie haben dann schwere Bedenken wegen des Fernmeldegeheimnisses. Das ist natürlich Unsinn, weil äh weil die Daten eben nochmal verschlüsselt sind. Und wenn du den Krypto-Kief von anderen nicht hast, kannst du äh deren deren Traffic auch nicht entschlüsseln.
Wir hatten, glaube ich, als,
ursprünglich mal diese Routerzwanggeschichte in die andere Richtung umzuschlagen drohte da uns schon mal länger darüber unterhalten, eine Sendung, auf die man mal verweisen könnte, wenn ich nur wüsste, welche das jetzt gewesen ist. Ähm
wo wir ja auch herausgestellt haben, soweit ich mich erinnere dass man das ja sehr wohl differenziert betrachten kann,
ja? Ich kann ja jetzt den Kabelmodell Provider dahingehend verstehen,
dass er jetzt, was die unmittelbare Kommunikation mit dem Netz, also eben diese unmittelbare Deko des ähm.
Der Kommunikation mit dem Netz auf der aller niedrigsten Ebene, ja, dass sie da ein großes Interesse daran haben, zum Beispiel die Firmware zu kontrollieren und zu aktualisieren,
Da gehe ich sogar mit. Weil wir haben ja auch gesehen, was es für ein Problem ist, wenn Leute veraltete äh oder eben auch wirklich schlecht
programmierte
Router benutzen, die keine Softwareupdates mehr sehen und die einfach tonnenweise äh Sicherheitslöser äh öffnen und die halt unter Umständen auch eine Weiterentwicklung des Netzes, also neue Versionen von äh entsprechenden Transmissionsstandards und so weiter nicht ermöglichen.
Das halte ich durchaus für so einen validen Punkt. Nur dass halt
in dieser ganzen Debatte um diese Route eben in der Regel dann eben diese ganzen Kombigere, die alle möglichen Funktionen zusammenbringen äh mit drin sind.
Dann auch eben so ein Unwesen sehen, wie das jetzt Kabel Deutschland irgendwie
die Freischaltung von WLAN und so weiter pro Monat verkauft und so weiter, also was ja wirklich abenteuerlicher Hahnebücher Quatsch ist, ne
würde man halt diese Geräte besser voneinander trennen, ja? Und ganz klar sagen, ja hier, was so die allerniedrigste Ebene äh betrifft, ja, so ich finde zum Beispiel, es könnte eigentlich jeder Internetdienstleister,
geradezu dazu verpflichtet werden, einem Internet in Form einer Internetdose bereitzustellen, ja
Ähm äh gut, ich will das jetzt gar nicht weiter äh führen, dass es halt eine technische Diskussion. Also man kann darüber argumentieren, aber so wie es hier argumentiert wird, ist es natürlich wirklich
absoluter Unfug und äh man merkt, dass sie einfach mit allem wedeln, was sie gerade irgendwie in den in die Hand bekommen können, um sich hier einer sinnvollen äh Regulierung oder Deregulierung zu entziehen.
Ja, also diese Argumente, wie gesagt, im Mobilfunkmarkt siehst du es, du das Baseball funktioniert und ähm,
ähnlich wäre das ja bei Kabel wurde im Herstellern auch, ja, also das ist ähm das Argument trägt nicht, aber sie versuchen eben wirklich da dafür zu sorgen, irgendwie sich sich diese Sache zu retten, weil damit eben Kundenbindung und Geschäftsmodelle einhergehen. Und,
deshalb ist es ja auch wichtig, dass mal ähm da mal dem einen Riegel vorzuschieben.
Du kennst dich da ja aus, um das dem vielleicht gleich nochmal dem nächsten Kommentar da Vorschub zu leisten,
So ganz richtig ist das ja nicht, ne. Ich meine, dieser eine Teil, diese Basebands und so weiter, da kann ja nun auch nicht jeder machen, was er will, oder? So, dann gibt's ja auch irgendwie lizenzierte Unternehmen oder,
wie läuft das rechtlich der Zahl?
Genau. Du musst ja auf, also,
Um das nochmal kurz zu trennen, Baseballs gibt's im Mobilfunkbereich, damit eben nicht jeder jeder jedes kaputte Telefon da irgendwie rumfunken kann, wie ein Wirrer und das ist sehr von von dem Mobiltelefon getrennter eigener Bestandteil
ähm.
Der vielen auch Sorgen macht in in anderen, in anderen Fragen, aber wo man einfach sagt, okay, das, was was am Ende wirklich funkt und diese ganze Mobilkommunikation macht, das kaufst du dir als fertigen
und und klemmst das bei dir rein, aber das kannst du natürlich trotzdem auch updaten.
Ja, aber darf denn jeder so was herstellen oder ist das äh mit einer Lizenz verbunden? Also darf jeder ein Baseband bauen.
Du musst nicht unbedingt eins bauen, du kannst dir halt auch so eine, so ein so einen digitalen Transiver holen, ne, so ein Hack A F und dann machst du einfach, was du willst.
Ja und das ist auch.
Ähm also aber natürlich du kannst nicht einfach, du kannst du kannst im Zweifelsfall nicht einfach hingehen,
und du gehst im Zweifelsfall nicht einfach hin und implementierst diesen ganzen Baseball-Kram selbst, was auch ein bisschen zu kompliziert ist. Das heißt, du kaufst halt eher fertig. Also bei den, bei den Mobiltelefonen, bei den Smartphones ist das so, dass es zwei oder.
Zwei oder drei größere Hersteller gibt, die deren Basebands dann in allen Telefonen drin sind.
Ja gut, aber die eigentliche Frage ist ja, dürfte es jeder tun.
Ich glaube schon, dass jeder alles herstellen darf, aber du musst wahrscheinlich dein Telefon am Ende bevor das Telefon betrieben werden kann, muss das natürlich alle möglichen Tests äh unterlaufen. Und das ist sicherlich ein sehr, sehr ausführlicher Prozess, bevor du, bevor dein Telefon zugelassen wird.
Von wem.
In den jeweiligen Ländern oder von den,
also ich gleich in den USA halt von der FCC, was weiß ich was für ein äh was für ein schau mal hinten drauf, was also FCC Logo hat das iPhone CE-Logo ähm und noch ein paar andere Logos, die ich nicht kenne, also haben wir nicht in den Müll werfen und irgendwas mit dem Auspuff.
Ergo CE, kann man selber draufkleben, das ist jetzt nix.
Gut, aber der, also der entscheidende Punkt ist, damit dein Telefon als Telefon zugelassen wird, muss es den Standards genügen,
ob du die Standards jetzt selber implementierst oder ob du die von von Fall kommen oder von von Infinion oder von wem auch immer irgendwas kaufst und das in dein Telefon reinlötest, was fertig ist, das bleibt dir natürlich erstmal selber überlassen.
Okay, aber es gibt sozusagen eine Instanz.
Dass das fertige Ding zu kaufen.
Ja, also es gibt eine Instanze des sicherstellt und äh das in dem Fall die FCC und wenn man das jetzt mal auf diese Netzprovider äh Situation überträgt. Ja, dann.
Dann wärst du genau da, dass das eben Ding nicht Kabelmodell heißen kann, wenn's irgendwie das Kabelnetz des Betreibers äh los ähm äh platt legt,
und dass genau du, wie du in den USA. Ich meine, selbst nimm doch das Beispiel, das also habe ich am Anfang gesagt, in den USA steht Kabelmodem.
Folgende Geräte könnt ihr gerne anschließen. Sind gut getestet.
Hm. Ja und hier ist es halt derzeit noch nicht so, aber demnächst wird es dann so sein, wenn denn dieses Gesetz auf
den Weg kommt, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich konkret auf dem Weg? Also wir hatten das, glaube ich, zuletzt besprochen, da war das noch eine Gesetzesvorlage. Jetzt ist die schon
abgenickt worden von der Regierung oder.
Nein, das ist jetzt gerade ein ähm Presseentwurf äh äh der Gesetzesentwurf, der jetzt da kommentiert wird, aber der wird jetzt,
großer Wahrscheinlichkeit zu kommen. Und das ist auch gut so, weil noch mal, ich will jetzt gerade auch so ein bisschen ähm,
Ich bin da so ein, ich finde das gut, dass wir den den diese Argumente der der Kabelnetzbetreiber hier ähm diskutieren, aber am Ende geht es hier,
darum, ähm einen Verbraucherschutz zu erreichen und den zu den Leuten die Herrschaft über das gerät, was in ihrem Wohnzimmer steht, zu ähm
zu geben. Und nicht darum, dass irgendjemand mit einem kaputten ähm mit einer kaputten äh Routerbox das das Netz darm legen möchte. Wenn ich das machen wollen würde, dann würde ich einfach zwei Kabel da dranhalten.
Und ähm da einfach irgendeinen kaputt moduliertes Signal reinwerfen,
Ja, also das heißt, die Stabilität des Netzes oder die Integrität der Kommunikation anderer ist nicht mehr oder weniger gefährdet, dadurch dass das Menschen ähm andere entsprechende Modems benutzen können.
Ja, also am Ende geht's geht's geht's geht's darum, dass wir eben nicht äh Geräte in unserem eigenen Zimmer stehen haben, wo wir Geld dafür ausgeben müssen, dass dass die das eine bestimmte Funktion daran aktiviert wird oder nicht.
So viel zu dieser Kurzmeldung.
Genau, das war eigentlich schön kurz. Die Meldung war eigentlich kurz.
Die Meldung war kurz. Ähm in der europäischen Kommission gibt es gerade eine interessante.
Meinungsverschiedenheit zwischen Andros Antipp, dem Vizepräsidenten äh der Europäischen Kommission und dem Kommissar für den digitalen Binnenmarkt und unserem Herrn Oettinger. Und zwar hat anderes gesagt, dieses ganze Geoblocking,
Ist Mist, das muss weg.
Oettinger hat dann der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung gesagt, Moment einmal, wir wollen ja jetzt hier nicht das Kind mit dem Bade ausschütten. Und ähm hält also an dem Geoblocking fest Geoblocking heißt also, dass Internetangebote.
Ähm nur bestimmten oder beschränkt werden auf IP-Adressbereiche.
Die bekanntermaßen bestimmten Ländern zugeordnet sind und ähm.
Wie gesagt, anderes hat also gesagt, ähm dass irgendwie so,
Solche Einschränkungen abgeschafft werden sollen, damit wir hier ein freies Netz haben und so und Ettinger, Oettinger sagte, ist euch ein Schritt dürfe nicht zu Lasten der kleineren gehen. Wir wollen unsere kulturelle Vielfalt bewahren,
und er möchte vor allem nicht nachher auf ein Ende der Filmwirtschaft äh hinarbeiten. Also wir sehen da dieser Oettinger ist wirklich ähm.
Sehr ähm konservativ.
Neues kommt da auf jeden Fall nicht, nee.
Sein, dass ihm ein vertraute Thema angeht.
Und ähm als letzte Meldung ähm ist, glaube ich, nur noch zu vermelden, dass.
Als dieses Flugzeug abgestürzt ist, das ist ja in der vergangenen Woche ein äh Flugzeug der Germanwings abgestürzt.
Mhm.
Oder abgestürzt worden, wie es im Moment erscheint,
die äh das, was in diesem Flugzeug geschehen ist, ist ähm.
Bisher nicht sinnvoll zu erklären. Wir müssen aber sagen, heute ist äh Freitag, der der dritte April und es wurde gerade der zweite Flugschreiber gefunden, also nichts Genaues weiß man nicht und an irgendwelchen
Spekulation will man sich da jetzt auch nicht beteiligen, aber es ist ein Flugzeug runtergekommen und es sieht so aus, als wäre.
Ist der Copilot selber gewesen, äh der dieses Flugzeug äh da an den Bergen hat, zerschellen lassen und zwar offenbar nach momentanem Kenntnisstand absichtlich. Und.
Wenn so ein Flugzeug runterkommt, dann muss ja der Innenminister irgendwas tun und.
Als das letzte Mal einen äh großes Flugzeugunglück gab, was ähm,
uns alle für so lange Zeit beschäftigt hat und noch sehr viel längere Zeit, da war das äh am elften September.
Und die eine, die eine der Ergebnisse dieses elften Septembers war ja, dass man gesagt hat, okay, diese Cockpit-Türen ähm,
müssen verstärkt werden und es muss eine Option geben, ähm diese Cockpittüren so zu verschließen,
dass man von außen keinesfalls reinkommt. Also verstärkte Türen, anderes Verschlusssystem. Und.
Diese Technik hat es so ist der aktuelle Kenntnisstand ähm verhindert, dass dieser Copilot,
an seiner Aktion da gehindert werden könnte. Also es hat eine die letzte neue Sicherheitsmaßnahme, die in Flugzeuge eingebaut wurde, hat eine entscheidende Rolle dabei gespielt, dass jetzt,
vierzehn Jahre äh später nochmal ein ein schreckliches Unglück stattfinden konnte.
Und da habe ich mich natürlich schon sehr gefragt, wie reagiert denn so unser de Maizire darauf, weil der muss jetzt trotzdem
irgendeine Verschärfung verlangen, der kann ja nicht einfach sagen, okay, wir machen die Türen wieder weicher, weil dann rennen ja die Terroristen da rein. Also muss er jetzt irgendwie die Fluggesellschaften haben natürlich dann gesagt, ja jetzt hier zwei Personen
Vier Augenprinzip im Cockpit und jetzt musste aber natürlich der de Maizire dieses,
Es ist diesen Vorfall ja trotzdem für seine Themen ausnutzen, um irgendwie eine eine Einschränkung unserer Freiheitsrechte vorzunehmen und ich war lange Zeit erst gespannt, was ihm denn einfallen würde,
Und was ihnen jetzt eingefallen ist, ja wir wir weichen einfach wieder die die,
oder wir schränken wieder die Reisefreiheit in Schengen, im Schengenraum ein, denn da es sich hier um einen Schengenflug gehandelt hat, ähm mussten sich zwar alle Personen.
Ähm namentlich registrieren für diesen Flug, wurden ja aber nicht irgendwie am, am Eingang zum Flugzeug erkennungsdienstlich behandelt und mussten keinen Ausweis zeigen. Und jetzt möchte er,
gerne die Ausweispflicht wieder einführen auf ähm innerdeutschen und innereuropäischen Flügen.
Also es ist wirklich absurd. Vor allem das ganze Argument ist ja äh man hätte ja nicht sofort gewusst, wer da jetzt gestorben sei. Ja, also äh als ob.
Ja das genau, das war sein Hauptproblem. Wir wussten ja gar nicht, wer an Bord war. Ne? Das kann ja, kann ja jeder kommen.
Ja hätte ja jetzt irgendjemand keine Ahnung, faken können oder so. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wo das Problem ist
Also ich meine, ist schon relativ offensichtlich, wer jetzt vermisst wurde, wer da irgendwie wahrscheinlich da war. Man kann wohl davon ausgehen, dass im allerbesten Fall vielleicht bei einer einzigen Person in irgendeiner Form vielleicht unter Umständen Unklarheit ist, ob sie nun wirklich an Bord sind oder nicht. Wobei
das wird ja an sich erstmal schon registriert, also dass da eine Person ist, klar, ja, also da ist sozusagen eine Person unter Umständen ähm
weiß ich nicht, wird wird nicht vermisst, aber sie sind die Person dann da, die eigentlich hätte an Bord sein müssen und dann vermutet man, das sei eine andere. Also ich es ist ja auch überhaupt nichts darüber berichtet worden, dass es irgendeine Unklarheit äh gegeben hätte.
Nein, das ist das ist absolut, das ist absoluter Unsinn und der Hintergrund ist natürlich ein ganz anderer, denn es geht um die äh um die das Sammeln von Passenger Names.
Ähm da gibt's jetzt gerade auf EU-Ebene ähm die den Vorschlag der Flugkasdaspeicherung,
man sagt, wir wollen fünf Jahre lang.
Unter anderem gespeichern wer, wann, mit wem, wohin geflogen ist, mit welcher Kreditkarte bezahlt hat und alle Daten, die ähm,
Die Fluggesellschaften eben über.
Personen sammeln, dazu gehört dann eben also bei mir ist dann halt ein Häkchen, weil äh Vegetarier, ne und dann äh das steht dann in meinem Passenger Name Record drin und darüber wollen die dann eine äh
eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung für mehrere Jahre machen, um eben darin eine Rasterfahndung durchführen zu können.
Und da ist es natürlich denen im Weg, wenn Personen sich innereuropäisch auf einmal,
theoretisch unidentifiziert bewegen können. Kleiner Hinweis an dieser Stelle, diejenigen, die mit diesen äh Holzfliegern fliegen, also Germanwings oder äh äh Ryanair oder so, die werden sich,
äh nicht Germanwings, sorry, ähm EasyJet und äh Ryanair, wo bei Germany's ja ja auch schon auf dem Weg ist in dieses in dieses Segment. Ähm da wird man nach dem Ausweis gefragt, aber nicht
weil ähm die sicherstellen wollen, dass man kein Terrorist ist, sondern weil die sicherstellen wollen, dass man diese Schleudertickets nicht ähm am Anfang auf Vorrat kauft und dann ähm,
auf eBay verhöckert, ja? Ähm also grundsätzlich gilt, wenn ich innereuropäisch fliege, muss ich meinen Ausweis nicht zeigen.
Ähm und die Airlines, die das trotzdem machen,
die machen das aus aus anderen Gründen, aber nicht aufgrund einer auf einer gesetzlichen Notwendigkeit.
Naja, aber ähm genau, sie wollen also jetzt hier diese diese Fluggastvorratsdatenspeicherung ähm etablieren
und da gibt's auch gerade eine sehr große Bewegung gegen und ich hoffe, dass wir in der nächsten Folge Logbuch Netzpolitik da auch mal äh einen Experten zu diesem Thema
haben können. Aber es ist natürlich ganz interessant ähm was wir dann demnächst bei Zugunglücken machen, ne. Stell dir mal vor, also als dieser,
dieses Zugunglück dabei bei Enschede, ne? Da wusstest ja überhaupt nicht, wer da drin war.
Ja ja.
Autounfall, ne? Muss ja auch erstmal sehr fürchterlich, wenn du dann erstmal in die ersten Stunden vielleicht gar nicht weißt, wer da an Bord war und wer da nicht an Bord war. Also es ist eine ähm es ist eine.
Wie nennt man das denn? Es ist, was der macht,
dieses äh dieses Unglück auszunutzen ähm für diese Überwachungsüberlegungen da. Und ähm der Mann ist sich dafür nicht zu schade, das wollte ich an dieser Stelle einfach nochmal kurz festhalten.
Ja, ich hoffe, dass dass wir diese Debatte nie führen müssen über Züge, obwohl ich das irgendwie mein Optimismus da auch etwas versagt.
Ach so, weil du hier der der Zuge, Züge.
Ja, ich meine, wenn man sich jetzt mal so Fliegen und Züge anschaut, ja, und wie so das Gefährdungspotential.
In dieser Terrorbedrohungslogik äh ist,
Ist ja klar, dass im Prinzip Züge genauso angreifbar sind. Ja und ich meine, wir hatten das ja nun auch schon in Spanien. Wann war das? Zweitausenddrei oder vier,
Okay, ja, findet statt. Ja, es ist, ist, ist ein Problem, ist auch furchtbar und so weiter. Ähm,
Aber wir sehen, dass diese die da so im Transportwesen äh sind eben noch nicht mal nur aus aus Terror heraus äh entstehen. Das finde ich überall,
den schlechten Nachrichten, die mit dem Flugzeugabsturz äh verbunden sind, ähm noch irgendwie die gute Nachricht. Trotz alledem,
Solche Forderungen, ja, mit diesem Überwachungswahn, das sicher beliebig steigern und
ich weiß gar nicht, irgendwann habe ich auch schon mal so jemanden über sowas reden hören, also ich kann mir da überhaupt nicht vorstellen, dass ich am Bahnhof dann, weißt du, dass man da sozusagen noch so einen Personencheck macht, äh dass jeder, der in Zug einsteigt durch irgend so ein,
Metalldetektor laufen muss, also seine Schuhe ausziehen muss, man ist totale.
Dass wir einfach die Kapitulation. Ich habe jetzt schon immer Probleme mit Fliegen und diesen ganzen Sicherheitsprozedoren, die ich für vollkommen albern und überflüssig halte, ne? Zumal sich ja jetzt eben auch an diesem Fall wieder gezeigt hat,
dass es eben auch ein sehr viel größeres Sicherheitsproblem wenn überhaupt gibt, äh sozusagen im Bereich der privilegierten Zugang haben, denn.
Also oh man, jetzt wird das Thema auch wieder länger, ne, aber jetzt kann ich mal nur kurz eine Geschichte erzählen. Ich habe mal ähm am Flughafen Tegel
beim Aussteigen aus dem Flugzeug mein Laptop dadrin liegen lassen, ja? Bin ich irgendwie
marschiert dann so aus dem Flugzeug raus, laufe durch den Finger, in Tegel ist das so, da ist dann sofort dieses Gepäckband, ne. Da laufe ich aber natürlich dran vorbei und
dann kommt da dieser Zollständer und so weiter und dann ist man schon draußen, ja? Das ist gibt glaube ich keinen anderen Flughafen, wo das so schnell und so äh so mit so wenigen Schritten möglich ist.
In der Welt.
Beste Flughafen der Welt. Ja und ähm dann gehe ich da also raus und quasi auf dem auf der Schwelle zwischen dem Sicherheitsbereich und dem
öffentlichen Bereich fällt mir ein Mist, Computer vergessen und ich drehe um,
Und ähm das ist ja aber dann so ein Schleuse. Und das ist ja so eine Schleuse, ne? Und dann machte dieser dies dieser Ausgang von der Schleuse wurde also bewacht von so einem Securitas Heini. Und der machte dann einen riesen Aufstand, weil ich jetzt grade, ne,
das eine Ding verstoßen habe, zu dessen Zweck er da saß, nämlich, dass keiner von dem einen, ne, von dem Bereich in den anderen ging.
Und dann habe ich also eine eine längere Debatte mit dem Mann angefangen und half alles nix und dann habe ich irgendwie wollte ich brauchte diesen Rechner, ja und dann habe ich ähm.
Bin ich schnell zu dem zu einem anderen Personal von der Airline gerannt und habe gesagt, hier Problem, ne, sag mal dem Piloten Bescheid, die sollen das mit rausnehmen. Die waren zu dem Zeitpunkt aber dann schon wieder weggefahren von dem Finger, weil die ja mit ihrem Flugzeug dann woanders hinfahren und parken und ähm
dann rannte aber dieser Typ sagte, kein Problem, ich habe hier Cleverness überall hin,
ja? Und rannte dann zu diesem Security-Typen, hielt seinen Ausweis hoch in der Security Typ, sagte nix, nix, nix. Verpisst euch, ja? Und dann macht ihr dann, dann diskutierten die da und ähm
beschimpfen sich gegenseitig und so und ich beschimpfe natürlich mit und große Debatte. Und während wir dann da so diskutierten,
zwei so Typen mit mit Leuchtwesten an. Die schoben so eine Reihe von diesen Koffertrollies.
Machten dann in diesem Sicher, von diesem Sicherheitsbereich ein Glas Segment mit einem Schlüssel auf,
und schoben da die Trollis in den Sicherheitsbereich rein, um die da wieder hinzustellen, denn die Fluggäste kommen ja, warten auf ihren Koffer, tun den auf den aus dem Sicherheitsbereich raus, steigen in ein Taxi, lassen den Trolley da stehen.
Und diese beiden Typen waren dafür angestellt worden, diese wieder zurückzubringen. Und dazu haben sie einen gesonderten Schlüssel zum Sicherheitsbereich gehabt, wo sie einfach,
in den Sicherheitsbereich, unkontrolliert, unbesehen, rein und rausgehen konnten.
Und ich habe da eine riesige Debatte geführt, weil ich rückwärts gehen wollte, um meinen scheiß Laptop zu bekommen.
Das war so eine, das war so eine Situation ausm Film, ne. Also wo du wo du so denkst so, ah, wunderbar. Du musst du musst noch nicht mal der Securitas Futzi werden, der da draußen sitzt und nur eine Aufgabe hat,
und wahrscheinlich noch einen Euro mehr die Stunde verdient als die. Du musst einfach nur werden. Dann hast du freien Zugang zu den zu den Sicherheitsbereichen.
Unter Umgehung aller Kontrollen. Ja und solche Geschichten erzählen dir,
hunderte den ganzen Tag. Ja, da kannst du ja, wenn dir die Flughafenmitarbeiter und so weiter, ja, dieses gesamte Security-Theater, man muss sich, glaube ich, einfach damit anfreunden.
Dass wir, wer sich in einen mehrere Tonnen schweres Objekt begibt, was durch die Luft fliegt,
ein äh gewisses Restrisiko in Kauf nimmt, dass alle sinnvollen Maßnahmen ergriffen wurden.
Noch ein paar sinnvolle gibt, die man noch ergreifen könnte, aber man dieses Unterfangen nicht sicherer macht,
durch mehr unsinnige Maßnahmen,
Verstehe zum Beispiel nicht diese diese Einzel äh Päckchen da, Einzel äh irgendwie darf man nur hundert Milliliter pro Flasche. Ich darf aber zehn von den Flaschen mitnehmen oder oder fünf von den Flaschen.
Ja.
Ein Kilofit. Was meinst du wie viel Liter Chemie ich in in mit fünf bis zehn Freunden? In diesen Sicherheitsbereich kriege. Das ist doch alles Unsinn.
Ja, es ist wirklich alles Unsinn und es ist halt nur so ein Sicherheitstanz, um irgendwie allgemeine Beruhigung zu machen, aber es dauert einfach alles ewig, ja.
Der Begriff, der da geprägt wurde, natürlich von, ich glaube, Bruce Schneider ist äh Security Fiater.
Es ist ein Sicherheitstheater. Man macht eine möglichst lange, große Vorstellung, wo jemand noch die Schuhe ausziehen muss und so. Und dann haben sie alle ihre Schuhe ausgezogen. Jetzt müssen wir aber wirklich sicher sein, ne. Und in der Lounge liegen dann Messer und Gabel,
weißt du also das ist alles okay.
So sieht's aus.
Das war wieder eine Folge. Wenn wir, wenn wir so eine richtig schön kurze machen wollen, dann dann wird's eine richtig schön lange. Und wir schweifen bei jedem Thema ab.
Sollte man eine ausführliche Sendung planen.
Nach meiner ausführlichen.
Wo wir jetzt noch dabei sind, musst du noch mal erzählen, du hast noch ein kleines Hörer äh Treffen in München gehabt oder kam's dazu nicht?
Kurzfristig. Ja, ich war cool, also ganz kurzfristig äh war ich da einen Abend in München und hatte dann gesagt, lasst doch mal wer wo treffen sich denn hier die Podcaster? Und dann habe ich direkt den den Münchner Podcaster Stammtisch der Drei,
Der fand nämlich da statt. Also es war gar kein Hörertreffen, sondern es war einfach ein äh Besuch auf dem Münchner Podcast da
Podcast, Hörer und Podca
und Podcast-Hörerinnen, Stammtisch und war sehr nett, ja, war in München in einem in einem Lokal und die hatten da ein ein Bier und mit dem Namen das kann ich auch vorher schon, aber es ist natürlich klar, dass man das dann trinken muss. Ähm Hackup.
Wahrscheinlich falsch ausgesprochen, aber das, dass er mal getrunken und ähm Schwätzle gegessen und so und war sehr, war sehr lustig.
Gut, Dinos. Dann können wir jetzt wirklich die Sendung beenden.
Genau, meine Güte, was ein Kampf, ey. Und ich muss ins Bett. Ähm herzlichen Dank an dieser Stelle an den guten Reiko.
Genau. Und herzlichen Dank an alle Hörer und die hier die Sendung unterstützen. Wir sagen tschüss.
Ciao.